the following is a conversation with
john le [ __ ] his second time in the
podcast he is the chief ai scientist at
meta formerly facebook professor at nyu
touring award winner one of the seminal
figures in the history of machine
learning and artificial intelligence
and someone who is brilliant and
opinionated in the best kind of way and
so is always fun to talk to
this is a lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now here's my
conversation with yon lacoon
you co-wrote the article self-supervised
learning the dark matter of intelligence
great title by the way with ishan mizrah
so let me ask what is self-supervised
learning and why is it the dark matter
of intelligence
i'll start by the dark matter part
uh
there is obviously a kind of learning
that humans and animals are
are doing that we currently are not
reproducing properly with machines with
ai right so the most popular approaches
to machine learning today are
or paradigms i should say are supervised
running and reinforcement learning
and they are extremely inefficient
supervised learning requires many
samples for learning anything
and reinforcement learning requires a
ridiculously large number of
trials and errors to for you know a
system to run anything
and that's why we don't have
self-driving cars
that's a big leap from one to the other
okay so that to solve difficult problems
you have to have a lot of uh human
annotation for supervised learning to
work and to solve those difficult
problems with reinforcement learning you
have to have
some way to maybe simulate that problem
such that you can do that large scale
kind of learning that reinforcement
learning requires right so how is it
that you know most teenagers can learn
to drive a car in about 20 hours of
practice
whereas uh even with millions of hours
of
simulated practice a self-driving car
can't actually learn to drive itself
properly
um and so obviously we're missing
something right and it's quite obvious
for a lot of people that
you know the immediate response you get
from
many people is well you know humans use
their background knowledge
to learn faster and they're right
now how was that background knowledge
acquired and that's the big question
so now you have to ask
you know how do
babies in the first few months of life
learn how the world works
mostly by observation because they can
hardly act in the world
and they learn an enormous amount of
background knowledge about the world
that may be the
the basis of what we call common sense
this type of learning
it's not learning a task it's not
being reinforced for anything it's just
observing the world and figuring out how
it works
building world models learning world
models
how do we do this and how do we
reproduce this in in machines so cell
supervision learning
is
you know one
instance or one attempt at trying to
reproduce this kind of learning
okay so
you're looking at just observation so
not even the interacting part of a child
it's just sitting there watching mom and
dad walk around pick up stuff
all of that that's the that's what you
mean by background knowledge perhaps not
even watching mom and dad just you know
watching the world go by
just having eyes open or having eyes
closed or the very act of opening and
closing eyes
that the world appears and disappears
all that basic information
and you're saying in in order to learn
to drive
like the reason humans are able to learn
to drive quickly some faster than others
is because of the background knowledge
they were able to watch cars operate in
the world
in the many years leading up to it the
physics of basics objects all that kind
of stuff that's right i mean the basic
physics of objects you don't even know
you don't even need to know you know how
a car works right because that you can
learn fairly quickly i mean the example
i use very often is uh you're driving
next to a cliff
and you know in advance because of your
you know understanding of intuitive
physics that if you turn the wheel to
the right the car will veer to the right
we'll run off the cliff
fall off the cliff and nothing good will
come out of this right
um but if you are a sort of
you know tabularized reinforcement
learning system that doesn't have a
model of the world
you have to repeat falling off this
cliff thousands of times before you
figure out it's a bad idea and then a
few more thousand times before you
figure out how to not do it and then a
few more million times before you figure
out how to not do it in every situation
you ever encounter
so self-supervised learning still has to
have
some source of truth
being told to it by somebody and is so
you have to figure out a way without
human
assistance or without significant amount
of human assistance to get that truth
from the world
so the mystery there is um
how much signal is there how much truth
is there that the world gives you
whether it's the human world
like you watch youtube or something like
that or it's the more natural world
so how much signal is there
so here's the trick there is way more
signal
in sort of a self-supervised setting
than there is in either a supervised or
reinforcement setting
and this is going to my you know analogy
of the cake
the you know low cake as someone has
called it where
when you try to figure out how much
information you ask the machine to
predict and how much feedback you give
the machine at every trial
in reinforcement learning you give the
machine a single scaler you tell the
machine you did good you did bad and you
you and you only
tell this to the machine once in a while
when i say you it could be the the
universe telling the machine right
but it's just one scalar so as a
consequence there is you you cannot
possibly learn something very
complicated without many many many
trials where you get many many feedbacks
of this type
supervision you you give a few bits to
the machine
at every every sample
let's say you're training a
system on you know recognizing images on
imagenet there is 1000 categories that a
little less than 10 bits of information
per sample
but star supervisory here is a setting
you
ideally we don't know how to do this yet
but ideally you would
show a machine a segment of
a video and then stop the video and ask
me ask the machine to predict what's
going to happen next
so you let the machine predict and then
you let time
go by and show the machine what actually
happened and hope the machine will you
know learn to do a better job at
predicting next time around there's a
huge amount of information you give the
machine because it's an entire video
clip
of uh you know of the future after the
video clip you fed it
in the first place so both for language
and for vision
there's a
subtle seemingly trivial construction
but maybe that's representative of what
is required to create intelligence which
is
filling the gap
so in the
gaps it
sounds dumb but can you
it's
it is possible you can solve all of
intelligence in this way just for both
language
just
give a sentence
and continue it or give a sentence and
there's a gap in it uh
some words blanked out and you fill in
what words go there
for vision
you give a sequence of images
and predict what's going to happen next
or you fill in what happened in between
do you think it's possible that
formulation alone
as a signal for self-supervised learning
can solve intelligence for vision and
language i think that's our best shot at
the moment um so whether this will take
us all the way to you know human level
intelligence or something or just cat
level intelligence
uh it's not clear but
among all the possible approaches that
people have proposed i think is our best
shot so
i think this idea of uh
an intelligent system filling in the
blanks either
you know predicting the future inferring
the past
filling in missing information
uh you know i'm currently filling the
blank of what is behind your head and
what you what your head looks like and
you know from from the back uh because i
have you know basic knowledge about how
humans are made and i don't know if
you're gonna you know what are you gonna
say at which point you're gonna speak
whether you're gonna move your head this
way or that way which way you're gonna
look but i know you're not gonna just
dematerialize and reappear three meters
uh
down the hall uh you know because i know
what's possible and what's impossible uh
according to into the physics so you
have a model of what's possible what's
impossible and then you'd be very
surprised if it happens and then you'll
have to reconstruct your model
right so that that's the model of the
world it's what tells you you know what
fills in the blanks so given your
partial information
about the state of the world given by
your perception
uh your your model of the world fills in
the missing information and that
includes predicting the future
retrodicting the past uh you know
filling in things you don't immediately
perceive and that doesn't have to be
purely
generic vision or visual information or
generic language you can go to specifics
like
predicting
what control decision you make when
you're driving in a lane you have a
sequence of images from a vehicle
and then you could
you have information if you recorded on
video where the car ended up going so
you can go back in time and predict what
the car went based on the visual
information that's very specific domain
specific
right but the question is whether we can
come up with sort of a generic
uh method
for
you know training machines to do this
kind of prediction or filling in the
blanks so right now
uh this type of approach has been
unbelievably successful in the context
of natural language processing uh every
modern natural language processing is
pre-trained in self-supervised manner
to fill in the blanks to you you show it
a sequence of words you remove 10
percent of them and then you train some
gigantic neural net to predict the words
that are missing
that and once you've pre-trained that
network you can use the
internal representation learn by it as
input to
you know
something that you train supervised or
whatever that's been incredibly
successful not so successful in images
although it's making progress
and uh and it's based on uh sort of
manual data augmentation uh we can go
into this later but what has not been
successful yet is training for video so
getting a machine to learn to represent
the visual world for example
by just watching video nobody has really
succeeded in doing this okay well let's
kind of give a high level overview
what's the difference in
kind
and in difficulty between vision and
language so you said
people haven't been able to
really kind of crack the problem of
vision open in terms of self-supervised
learning but that may not be necessarily
because it's fundamentally more
difficult maybe like when we're talking
about achieving like passing
the turing test and the full spirit of
the turing test in language might be
harder than vision that's that's not
obvious so what in your view which is
harder
or perhaps are they just the same
problem when uh
the farther we get to solving each the
more we realize it's all the same thing
it's all the same cake i think
what i'm looking for are methods that
make make them look essentially like the
same cake but currently they're not and
the main issue
with
learning water models or learning
predictive models
is that
the prediction is never a single
thing
because the world is not entirely
predictable
it may be deterministic or stochastic we
can get into the philosophical
discussion about it but uh but even if
it's deterministic it's not entirely
predictable
and so
if i play
a short video clip and then i ask you to
predict what's going to happen next
there's many many plausible
continuations for that
video clip and the number of
continuation grows with the
interval of time that you're asking the
system to make a prediction uh for
and so
one big question with supervision is how
you
represent this uncertainty how you
represent
multiple discrete outcomes how you
represent a sort of continuum of
possible outcomes
etc and you know if you are a
sort of a classical machine learning
person you say oh you just represent a
distribution right
and that we know how to do
when we're predicting words missing
words in the text because
uh you can have a neural net give a
score for every word in a dictionary
it's a big you know it's a big list of
numbers you know maybe a hundred
thousand or so and you can turn them
into a probability distribution that
gives that tells you when i say a
sentence you know the
you know the cat is chasing the blank in
the kitchen
you know there are only a few words that
make sense there you know it could be a
mouse or it could be a laser spot or you
know something like that right
uh
and and if i if i say the the blank is
changing the blank in the savannah you
also have a bunch of plausible options
for those two words right
um that that because you you have kind
of a you know underlying reality that
you can refer to to sort of fill in
those those blanks
um
so
you cannot say for sure in the savannah
if it's a you know a lion or cheetah or
whatever you cannot know if it's a
zebra or
glue or you know whatever wildebeest the
same thing um
but uh
but you can represent the uncertainty by
just a long list of numbers now
if i uh if i do the same thing with
video and i ask you to predict a video
clip it's not a discrete set of
potential frames you have to have
somewhere representing a sort of
infinite number of plausible
continuations
of multiple frames in a you know high
dimensional continuous space and we just
have no idea how to do this properly
uh finite high dimensional
so like you because it's fine
dimensional yes just like the words i
try to get it to uh
down to a small finite set of like under
a million something like that something
like that i mean it's kind of ridiculous
that
we're
doing a distribution over every single
possible word for language and it works
it feels like that's a really dumb way
to do it
um like there seems to there seems to be
like there should be some more
compressed representation of the
distribution of the words you're right
about that and so i agree do you have
any interesting ideas about how to
represent all the reality in a
compressed way such you can form a
distribution over it that's one of the
big questions you know how do you do
that right i mean what's what's kind of
you know another thing that that really
is
stupid about um i shouldn't say stupid
but like simplistic about current
approaches to cell supervision in in uh
nlp in text
is that not only do you represent a
giant distribution over words but for
multiple words that are missing those
distributions are essentially
independent of each other
and you know you don't pay too much of a
price for this so you you so you can't
so the you know the system
you know in the the the sentence that i
gave earlier
if he gives a certain probability for a
lion and and uh cheetah and then a
certain probability for
uh you know gazelle uh wildebeest and
and and zebra
uh
those two probabilities are independent
of each other
uh and it's not the case that those
things are independent lions actually
attack like bigger animals than than she
does so
you know there's a huge independence
hypothesis in in this process which is
not actually true the reason for this is
that we don't know how to represent uh
properly distributions over
combinatorial uh sequences of symbols
essentially whenever because the number
goes exponentially with the length of
the of the symbols
and so we have to use tricks for this
but um those techniques can
you know get around like don't even deal
with it so
so the big question is like would there
be some sort of abstract
latent representation of text
that would say that
you know when i when i switch
lion for gazelle
lion for cheetah i also have to switch
zebra for gazelle
yeah so
this independence assumption let me
throw some criticism at you that i often
hear and see how you respond
so this kind of filling in the blanks is
just statistics you're not learning
anything
like the deep underlying concepts you're
just mimicking stuff from
the past you're not learning anything
new such that you can use it to
generalize about the world
or okay let me just say the crude
version which is it's just statistics
it's not intelligence uh what do you
have to say to that what do you usually
say to that if you kind of hear this
kind of thing i don't get into those
discussions because they are they're
kind of pointless um so first of all
it's quite possible that intelligence is
just statistics it's just statistics of
a particular kind yes uh where this is
the philosophical question it's kind of
is
is intel is it possible that
intelligence is just statistics yeah
but what kind of statistics so
uh if you are asking the question
are the model of the world the models of
the world that we learn um do they have
some notion of causality yes
so if the criticism comes from people
who say
you know current machine learning system
don't care about causality which by the
way is wrong
uh
you know i agree with them yeah you
should you know your model of the world
should have your actions as one of your
of the inputs
and that will drive you to learn causal
models of the world where you know what
you know what uh intervention in the
world will cause what results or you can
do this by observation of other agents
uh acting in the world and and observing
the effect
uh other humans for example so i think
you know at some level of description uh
intelligence is just statistics
uh but that doesn't mean you don't you
don't you know you won't have models
that have you know deep mechanistic
explanation for what goes on
uh the question is how do you learn them
that's that's the question i'm
interested in
uh because
you know a lot of people who actually
voice their criticism
say that those mechanistic model has to
have to come from someplace else they
have to come from human designers they
have to come from i don't know what and
obviously we learn them
or if we don't learn them as an
individual nature
learn them for us using evolution so
regardless of what you think those
processes have been learned somehow
so if you look at the the human brain
just like when we humans introspect
about how the brain works
it seems like when we think about what
is intelligence we think about
the high level stuff like the models
we've constructed concepts like
cognitive science like concepts of
memory
and reasoning module almost like these
high-level modules
is there's is this service a good
analogy
like are we ignoring
the uh
the dark matter the
the basic low-level mechanisms just like
we ignore the way the operating system
works we're just using the
uh the the high-level software we're
ignoring that
at the low level
the neural network might be doing
something like statistics
like me
sorry to use this word probably
incorrectly and crudely but doing this
kind of fill in the gap kind of learning
and just kind of updating the model
constantly in order to be able to
support the raw sensory information to
predict it and then adjust to the
prediction when it's wrong but like kyla
when we look at our brain at the high
level it feels like we're doing like
we're playing chess like
we're we're like playing with high level
concepts and we're stitching them
together and we're putting them into
long-term memory but really what's going
underneath
is something we're not able to
introspect which is this kind of
uh simple large neural network that's
just filling in the gaps right well okay
so there's a lot of questions there are
answers there okay so first of all
there's a whole school of thought in
neuroscience computational neuroscience
in particular
that likes the idea of predictive coding
which is really related to the idea i
was talking about in self-supervised
learning so everything is about
prediction the essence of intelligence
is the ability to predict
and everything the brain does is trying
to predict
uh predict everything from everything
else okay and that's really sort of the
underlying principle if you want that
uh cell supervisor learning is trying to
kind of reproduce this idea of
prediction that's kind of an essential
mechanism
of
task independent learning if you want
the next step is
what kind of intelligence are you
interested in reproducing and of course
you know we all think about you know
trying to reproduce sort of you know
high-level cognitive processes in humans
but like with machines we're not even at
the level of
even reproducing the
learning processes in a in a cat brain
um you know the most intelligent or
intelligent systems don't don't have as
much common sense as as a house cat
so um how is it that cats learn and you
know cats don't do a whole lot of uh
reasoning they certainly have causal
models they certainly have
uh because you know many cats can figure
out like how they can act on the world
to get what they want um they certainly
have uh a fantastic model of intuitive
physics uh certainly of the the the
dynamics of their own bodies but but
also of praise and things like that
right so
um they they're they're pretty smart
they only do this with about 800 million
neurons
we are not anywhere close to reproducing
this kind of
thing so to some extent i could i could
say
let's not even worry about like the high
level cognition
and kind of you know long-term planning
and reasoning that humans can do until
we figure out like you know can we even
reproduce what cats are doing
now that said this ability to
learn world models i think is the key to
the possibility of
learning machines that can also reason
so whenever i give a talk i'd say there
are there are three challenges in the
three main challenges in machine
learning the first one is
uh you know getting machines to learn to
represent the world
and proposing salt supervised running
the second is
getting machines to reason in ways that
are compatible with
essentially gradient-based learning
because this is what deep learning is
all about really
and the third one is something we have
no idea how to solve at least i have no
idea to solve
is uh
can we get machines to learn
hierarchical representations of action
plans
you know like you know we know how to
train them to learn hierarchical
representations of
perception you know with computational
nets and things like that and
transformers but what about action plans
can we uh get them to spontaneously
learn good hierarchical representations
of actions also gradient based
yeah all of that you know needs to be
somewhat differentiable so that you can
apply sort of gradient-based learning uh
which is really what deep learning is
about
so it's background
knowledge ability to reason in a way
this differentiable that
is somehow connected deeply integrated
with that background knowledge or builds
on top of that background knowledge and
then given that background knowledge be
able to make hierarchical plans right in
the world so if if you take classical
optimal control there's something in
classical optimal control called
uh
model predictive control
and it's you know it's been around since
the early 60s
nasa uses that to compute trajectories
of rockets and the basic idea is that
you have a pretty predictive model
of the rocket let's say or whatever
system you are you intend to control
which
given the state of the system at time t
and given an action
that you're taking the system so for
rocket to be thrust and you know all the
controls you can have
uh it gives you the state of the system
at time t plus delta t right so
basically a differential equation
something like that
um
and if you have this model and you have
this model
in the form of some sort of neural net
or some sort of uh set of formula that
you can back propagate gradient through
you can do what's called model
predictive control or gradient based
uh model predictive control so you have
uh you can unroll that
that model in time you you
you you feel it a
hypothesized sequence of actions
and then you have some objective
function that measures how well at the
end of the trajectory the system has
succeeded or matched what you wanted to
do
um you know is it a robot harm have you
grasped the object you want to grasp if
it's a rocket you know are you at the
right place near the space station
things like that
and by back propagation through time and
again this was invented in the 1960s by
optimal control theorists
you can figure out uh what is the
optimal sequence of actions that will
you know get my system to the the best
final state
so
that's a form of reasoning it's
basically planning and a lot of planning
uh systems in robotics are actually
based on this
and uh
and you can think of this as a form of
reasoning so
you know to take the example of the
teenager driving a car again you have a
pretty good dynamical model of the car
it doesn't need to be very accurate but
you know again that if you
turn the wheel to the right and there is
a cliff you're gonna run off the cliff
right you don't need to have a very
accurate model to predict that
and you can run this in your mind and
decide not to do it for that reason
because you can predict in advance that
the result is going to be bad so you can
sort of imagine different scenarios
and and then you know employ
uh or take the first step in the
scenario that is most favorable and then
repeat the process of planning that's
called receding horizon model predictive
control so even you know all those
things have names you know uh going back
you know decades um
and so
if you're not not uh you know classical
optimal control the model of the world
is not generally learned
uh there's you know sometimes a few
parameters you have to identify that's
called systems identification but
uh but generally
the model is
mostly deterministic and mostly built by
hand so the big question of ai
i think the big challenge of ai for the
next decade is how do we get machines to
learn predictive models of the world
that deal with uncertainty and deal with
the real world in all this complexity so
it's not just the trajectory of a rocket
which you can reduce to first principles
it's not it's not even just a trajectory
of a robot arm which again you can model
by you know careful mathematics but it's
everything else everything you observe
in the world you know people behavior
um you know physical systems that
involve collective phenomena
like water or or you know
trees and you know branches in a tree or
something or
or
like complex things that you know humans
have no trouble
developing abstract representations in
predictive model for but we still don't
know how to do with machines where do
you put in in these three maybe in the
in the planning stages
the game theoretic nature of this world
where your actions not only respond to
the dynamic nature of the world the
environment but also affected
so if there's other humans involved is
this is this
point number four or is it somehow
integrated into the hierarchical
representation of action in your view i
think it's integrated it's just um it's
just that now your model of the world
has to deal with you know it just makes
it more complicated right the fact that
uh humans are complicated and not easily
predictable
that makes your model of the world much
more complicated that much more
complicated well there's a chat i mean i
suppose chess is an analogy
so monte carlo tree search
there's a i go you go i go you go like
um andre kapatha recently gave a talk at
mit about car doors
i think there's some machine learning
too but mostly car doors and there's a
dynamic nature to the cart like the
person opening the door checking
and he wasn't talking about that he was
talking about the perception problem of
what the ontology of what defines a car
door this big philosophical question but
to me it was interesting because like
it's obvious that the person opening the
car doors they're trying to get out like
here in new york trying to get out of
the car
you slowing down is going to signal
something you speeding up is going to
signal something and that's a dance it's
a
asynchronous
chess game i don't know
so
i it feels like um
it's not just i mean i guess you can
integrate all of them into one giant
model like the entirety of the the
these little interactions because it's
not as complicated as chess it's just
like a little dance we do like a little
dance together and then we figure it out
well in some ways it's way more
complicated than chess because uh
because it's continuous it's uncertain
in a continuous manner
uh it doesn't feel more complicated but
it doesn't feel more complicated because
that's what we are we've evolved to
solve this is the kind of problem we've
evolved to solve and so we're good at it
because you know
nature has made us good at it
nature has not made us good at chess we
completely suck at chess yeah um
in fact that's why we designed it as a
game is to be challenging
and if there is something that you know
recent progress in chess and go
has made us realize is that humans are
really terrible at those things like
really bad you know there was a story
right before alphago that uh
uh you know the best go players thought
there were maybe two or three stones
behind you know an ideal player that
they would call god
uh in fact no they are like nine or ten
stones behind i mean we're just bad
so we're not good at and it's because we
have limited uh working memory we we're
not very good at like doing this uh tree
exploration that you know computers are
much better
at doing than we are but we are much
better at learning differentiable models
of the world
i mean i said differentiable in the kind
of
you know i should say
not differentiable in the sense that you
know we went back for up to it but in
the sense that
our brain has some mechanism for
estimating gradients uh of some kind
yeah and that's what you know makes us
uh efficient so if you have an agent
that consists of
a a model of the world which you know in
the human brain is basically the entire
front half of your brain
an objective function
which
uh in human in in humans is a
combination of two things there is your
sort of intrinsic motivation module
which is in the basal ganglia you know
at the base of your brain that's the
thing that measures pain and hunger and
things like that like immediate
feelings and emotions
and then there is
you know the equivalent of what people
in reform spectrum called a critic which
is a sort of module that predicts ahead
what the outcome
of a uh
of a situation will be
and so it's it's not a cost function but
it's sort of not an objective function
but it's sort of a
you know trained predictor of the
ultimate objective function and that
also is differentiable and so if all of
this is differentiable your cost
function your your critic your
uh
you know your your role model then you
can use
gradient-based type methods to do
planning to the reasoning to do learning
uh you know to do all the things that
would like an intelligent agent uh
to do
and the gradient-based learning like
what's your intuition that's probably at
the core of what can solve intelligence
so you don't need
like a
logic based reasoning uh in your view i
don't know how to make logic based
reasoning compatible with
efficient learning yeah and
okay i mean there is a big question
perhaps a philosophical question i mean
it's not that philosophical but uh that
we can ask is is that you know all the
learning
algorithms we know from engineering and
computer science
proceed by optimizing some objective
function
yeah right
so one question we may ask is
is
does learning in the brain minimize an
objective function
it could be a you know a composite of
multiple objective functions but it's
still an objective function
uh second if it does optimize an
objective function
does it do does it do it by
some sort of gradient estimation
you know it doesn't need to be back prop
but you know some way of estimating the
gradient in efficient manner
whose complexity is on the same order of
magnitude as you know actually running
the
inference
because you can't afford to do things
like you know perturbing a weight in
your brain to figure out what the effect
is and then sort of uh you know you can
do sort of estimating gradient by
perturbation it's it to me it seems very
imp implausible that the brain uses some
sort of
you know zeroth order black box gradient
free optimization
because it's so much less efficient than
gradient optimization so it has to have
a way of estimating gradients
is it possible that some kind of logic
based reasoning emerges in pockets as a
useful like you said if the brain is an
objective function maybe it's a
mechanism for creating objective
functions
it's it's a mechanism for
creating knowledge bases for example
that can then be queried like maybe it's
like an efficient representation of
knowledge that's learned in a
gradient-based way or something like
that well so i think there is a lot of
different types of
intelligence so first of all i think the
type of logical reasoning that we think
about
that we are
you know maybe stemming from
you know sort of classical ai of the
1970s and 80s
i think humans use that relatively
rarely
and are not particularly good at it but
we judge each other based on our ability
to uh
solve those rare problems it's called an
iq test i think so like i'm i'm not very
good at chess
yes i'm judging you this whole time
because
well we we actually with your with your
uh you know heritage i'm sure you're
good at chess
no stereotypes not all stereotypes are
true
well i'm terrible at chess so um
you know but i think perhaps uh another
type of intelligence that i have is this
uh
uh you know ability of sort of building
models of the world from
uh you know
reasoning obvious obviously but also
also data
and those those models generally are
more kind of analogical right so it's
it's
it's reasoning by simulation
and by analogy
where you use one model to apply to a
new situation even though you've never
seen that situation you can sort of
connect it to a situation you've
encountered before
uh and and your reasoning is more
you know akin to some sort of internal
simulation so you you're kind of
stimulating what's happening when you're
building i don't know a box out of wood
or something right you can imagine
in advance like what would be the result
of you know cutting the wood in this
particular way are you going to use you
know screws on nails or whatever
when you are interacting with someone
you also have a model of that person and
and sort of interact with that person
you know having this model in mind uh to
kind of
uh tell the person what you think is
useful to them so
i think this
this ability to construct most of the
world is
basically the essence the essence of
intelligence
and the ability to use it then to
plan uh actions that will
uh fulfill a particular criterion
of course is is necessary as well so i'm
going to ask you a series of impossible
questions as we keep asking is that been
doing so
so if that's the fundamental sort of
dark matter of intelligence this ability
to form a background model what's your
intuition about
how much knowledge is required
you know you know i think dark matter
you put a percentage
on it
of uh the composition of the universe
and how much of it is dark matter how
much of his dark energy how much
information do you think is required to
to be a house cat
so you have to be able to uh when you
see a box going it when you see a human
compute the most evil action
if there's a thing that's near an edge
you knock it off
all of that
plus the extra stuff you mentioned which
is a
great self-awareness of the physics of
your of your own body and in the world
how much knowledge is required do you
think to solve it um i don't even know
how to measure
an answer to that question i'm not sure
how to measure it but whatever it is it
fits in about about 800 000 neurons uh
800 million neurons or the
representation does
everything all knowledge everything
right
um
it was less than a billion a dog is two
billion but a cat is less than one
billion
and uh
so multiply that by a thousand and you
get the number of synapses and i think
almost all of it is is learned through
this you know a sort of supervised
running although you know i think a tiny
flavor is learned through reinforcement
running and certainly very little
through
you know classical supervised running
although it's not even clear how
supervised learning actually works in uh
in a biological world
um so i think almost all of it is uh is
self supervision but it's driven
by uh the the sort of ingrained
objective functions that a cat or human
have at the base of their brain which
kind of drives their
um their behavior so you know nature
tells us uh you're hungry
it doesn't tell us how to feed ourselves
that's that's something that the rest of
our brain has to figure out right
well it's interesting because there
might be more like deeper objective
functions underlying the whole thing
so
hunger may be some kind of
now you go to like neurobiology it might
be just the brain
uh
trying to maintain homeostasis
so hunger is just one of the
human perceivable
symptoms of the brain being unhappy with
the way things are currently right it
could be just like one really dumb
objective function at the core but
that's how that's how behavior is is
driven uh the the fact that you know the
orbital ganglia
uh drive us to do things that are that
are different from saying a wong tong or
certainly a cat
is what makes you know human nature
versus orangutan nature versus scat
nature
so for example
uh you know our basal ganglia drives us
to
seek the company of
other humans
and that's because nature has figured
out that we need to be social animals
for our species to survive and it's true
of many
primates
it's not true orangutons orangutans are
solitary animals um they don't seek the
company of others in fact they avoid
them
in fact they scream at them when they
come too close because they're
territorial
because for for their survival you know
uh evolution has figured out that's the
best thing
i mean they're occasionally social of
course for you know
reproduction and stuff like that but um
but but they're mostly solitary so
so all of those behaviors are not part
of intelligence you know people say oh
you're never going to have intelligent
machines because you know human
intelligence is social but then you look
at orangutans you look at octopus
octopus never know their parents
they barely interact with any other and
and they get to be really smart in less
than less than a year in like half a
year
you know in a year they're adults in two
years they're dead so
there are things that we think
as humans are intimately linked with
intelligence like
social interaction like language
we think i think we give way too much
importance to language as a substrate of
intelligence as humans
because we think our reasoning is so
linked with language so for to solve the
house cat intelligence problem you think
you could do it on a desert island you
could have pretty much you could just
have a cat sitting there
um
looking at the waves that the ocean
weighs and figure a lot of it out it
needs to have sort of you know the right
set of drives
uh to kind of
you know get it to do the thing and
learn the appropriate things right but
uh
like for example you know
baby humans are driven to
learn to stand up and walk
okay you know it's not that's kind of
this desire is hard-wired how to do it
precisely is not that's learned
but the desire to to walk move around
and stand up
that's sort of
probably hardwired it's very simple to
hardwire this kind of stuff
oh like the desire to well
that's interesting you're hardwired to
want to walk
that's not a
there's got to be a deeper need for
walking
i think it was probably socially imposed
by society that you need to walk all the
other bipedal
like a lot of simple animals that you
know would probably work without ever
watching any other members of the
species it seems like a scary thing to
have to do because you suck it by peter
walking at first it seems crawling is
much safer
much more
like why are you in a hurry
well because because you have this thing
that drives you to do it you know um
which is sort of part of uh the sort of
human development is that understood
actually what not entirely no what is
what's the reason to get on two feet
it's really hard like most animals don't
get on two feet well they get on four
feet you know many mammals get on four
feet yeah they very quickly some of them
extremely quickly
but i don't you know like from the last
time i've interacted with the table
that's much more stable than the thing
then two legs it's just a really hard
problem yeah how many birds have figured
it out with two feet
well technically we can go into ontology
they have four
i guess they have two feet they have two
feet chickens
you know dinosaurs had two feet many of
them allegedly
i'm just now learning that t-rex was
eating grass not other animals t-rex
might have been a friendly
friendly pet what do you think about uh
i don't know if you looked at
the test for general intelligence that
francois chile put together i don't know
if you got a chance to look at that kind
of thing like
what's your intuition about how to solve
like an iq type of test i don't know i
think it's so outside of my radar screen
that it's not really
relevant i think in the short term
well i guess one way to ask another way
perhaps more closer to what
to your work is like how do you solve
mnist uh with very little example data
that's right and that's the answer to
this probably is supervised running just
learn to represent images and then
learning
uh
you know to recognize handwritten digits
on top of this will only require a few
samples and we observe this in humans
right you you show a young child a
picture book with a couple pictures of
an elephant and that's it
the child knows what an elephant is and
we we see this today with practical
systems that we
you know we train image recognition
systems with
uh
enormous amounts of of images either
either completely self-supervised or
very weakly supervised for example
you can
train a
neural net to predict uh whatever
hashtag people type on instagram right
then you can do this with billions of
images because there's billions per day
that are showing up
so the
amount of training data there is
essentially unlimited
and then you take the output
representation
you know a couple layers down from the
output
of what the system learned
and feed this as input to a classifier
for any object in the world that you
want and it works pretty well so that's
transfer learning okay
or weekly supervised
transfer learning uh
people are making very very fast
progress using self-supervised running
uh for for with this kind of scenario as
well
um and you know my guess is that that's
that's gonna be the future for
self-supervised learning how much
cleaning do you think is needed for
filtering um
uh malicious signal or what's a better
term but like a lot of people use
hashtags on instagram
to uh get like good seo
that doesn't fully represent the
contents of the image
like they'll put a picture of a cat and
hashtag it would like science awesome
fun i don't know all kind of
why would you put science that's not
very good seo the way the way my
colleagues who worked on this project at
uh
at facebook now meta meta
a few years ago uh dealt with this is
that they only selected something like
17 000 tags that correspond to kind of
physical things or or situations like
you know that has some visual content
um
so you know
you wouldn't have like tbt or anything
like that
also they keep a very select set of
hashtags is what you're saying yeah okay
but it's still instead on the order of
uh you know 10 to 20 000 so it's fairly
large okay
can you uh tell me about data
augmentation what the heck is data
augmentation and how is it used maybe
contrast of learning
for uh
for video what are some cool ideas here
right so data augmentation i mean first
data augmentation you know is the idea
of artificially increasing the size of
your training set by distorting the
images that you have in ways that don't
change the nature of the image right so
you take you you're doing this you can
do data augmentation on any list and
people have done this since the 1990s
right you take a in this digit and you
shift it a little bit or you
change the size or
rotate it skew it
you know etc add noise
add noise etc and it it works better if
you train a supervised classifier with
augmented data you're going to get
better results
now it's become really interesting over
the last couple years because
a lot of supervised learning techniques
to pre-train vision systems are based on
data augmentation
and the
the basic techniques is originally
inspired by uh
techniques that
i worked on in the early 90s and jeff
intern worked on also in the early 90s
there was sort of parallel
work i used to call this siamese network
so basically you take
two identical copies of the same network
they share the same weights
and you show two
different views of the same object
either those two different views may
have been obtained by data augmentation
or maybe it's two different views of the
same scene from a camera that you moved
or at different times or something like
that right or two pictures of the same
person things like that
and then you train this neural net those
two identical copies of this neural net
to produce an output representation a
vector
in such a way that the representation
for those two
images
are as close to each other as possible
as identical to each other as possible
right because you want the system to
basically learn a function that will
that will be invariant that will not
change whose output will not change when
you transform those
inputs uh in in those in those
particular ways right
so that's easy to do
what's complicated is how do you make
sure that when you show two images that
are different the system will produce
different things
because if you don't
have a specific provision for this
the system will just ignore the input
when you train it it will end up
ignoring the input and just produce a
constant vector that is the same for
every input right yes that's called a
collapse
now how do you avoid collapse so there's
two ideas
one idea that i proposed in the early
90s with my colleagues at bell labs jane
bromley and a couple other people
which we now call contrastive learning
which is to have negative examples right
so you have pairs
of images that you know are different
and you show them to the network and
uh those two copies and then you you
push the two output vectors away from
each other
and they will eventually guarantee that
things that are semantically similar
produce similar representations and
things that are different produce
different representations
we actually came up with this idea for a
project of doing signature verification
so we would collect signature
signatures from like multiple signatures
on the same person and then train a
neural net to produce the same
representation
and then uh
you know
force the system to produce different
representations for different signatures
this was actually the the problem was
proposed by people from uh what was a
subsidiary of atnt at the time called
ncr
and they were interested in storing a
representation of the signature on the
80 bytes of the
magnetic strip of a credit card so we
came up with this idea of having a
neural net with 80 outputs
you know that we would quantize on bytes
so so that we could encode the
and that encoding was then used to
compare whether the signature matches or
not that's right so then you would you
know
sign you would run through the neural
net and then you would compare the
output vector to whatever is stored on
your card it actually worked
it worked but they ended up not using it
because nobody cares actually i mean the
american you know financial payment
system is
incredibly lags in that respect compared
to europe oh with the signatures what's
the purpose of signatures anyway this is
very nobody looks at them nobody cares
yeah it's uh yeah yeah no so so that
that's contrastive learning right so you
need positive and negative pairs and the
problem with that is that
you know even though i at the original
paper on this
i'm actually not very positive about it
because it doesn't work in high
dimension if your presentation is high
dimensional there's just too many ways
for two things to be different
and and so you would need lots and lots
and lots of negative pairs
so there is a particular implementation
of this which is relatively recent from
actually the google toronto group
uh where you know jeff intern is the
senior member there it's called sim
clear sim clr
and you know basically a particular way
of implementing this idea of contracting
running the particular objective
function
now
what i'm much more
enthusiastic about these days is
non-contrasting methods so other ways to
guarantee that
uh
the
representations would be different for
different
different inputs
and it's actually based on an idea that
jeff intern proposed in the early 90s
with a student at the time sue becker
and it's based on the idea of maximizing
the mutual information between the
outputs of the two systems you only show
positive pairs you only show pairs of
images that you know are somewhat
similar
and you train the two networks to be
informative
but also to be
as informative
of each other as possible so basically
one representation has to be predictable
from the other essentially
uh and you know he proposed that idea
had you know
a couple papers in the early 90s and
then nothing was done about it for
decades and i kind of revived this idea
together with my postdocs at fair
uh particularly a postdoc called
stefanoni who's now a junior professor
in in finland at university of alto
we came up with something called that we
call barlow twins
and it's a particular way of maximizing
the information content of
a vector you know using some
hypotheses
and we have kind of a
another version of it that's more recent
now called vikreg vic reg that that
means variance in variance covariance
regularization and i'm it's the thing
i'm the most excited about in machine
learning in the last 15 years i mean i'm
i'm not i'm really really excited about
this what uh kind of data augmentation
is useful for that non-contrasting
learning method
are we talking about does that not
matter that much or it seems like a very
important part of the step yeah how you
generate the images that are similar but
sufficiently different yeah that's right
it's an important step and it's also an
annoying step because you need to have
that knowledge of what the augmentation
you can do that do not change the nature
of the of the object
and so
the standard scenario which you know a
lot of people working in this area are
using is you use uh the the type of
distortion
so so basically you do geometric
distortion so one basically just shifts
the image a little bit it's called
crabbing another one kind of changes the
scale a little bit another one kind of
rotates it another one changes the
colors you know you can do a shift in
color balance or something like that
uh saturation another one sort of blurs
it another one adds noise so you have
like a catalog of kind of standard
things and people try to use the same
ones for different algorithms so that
they can compare
but some algorithms uh some cell
supervisor algorithm actually can deal
with much bigger
like more aggressive data augmentation
and some don't so
that kind of makes the whole thing
difficult but but that's the kind of
distortions we're talking about and
and so you you you you train with those
distortions
and then uh you
you chop off the last layer a couple
layers of the of the network
and you use the representation as input
to a classifier you train the classifier
um
on imagenet let's say or whatever and
measure the performance
and
interestingly enough the methods that
are really good at eliminating the
information that is irrelevant which is
the distortions between those images
do a good job at eliminating it
and uh as a consequence you cannot use
those the representations in those
systems for things like object detection
and localization because that
information is gone
so the type of data augmentation you
need to do depends on the task you want
eventually
the system to to solve and the type of
data augmentation standard data
determination that we use today are only
appropriate for object recognition or
image classification they're not
appropriate for things like can you help
me out understand what uh why the
localization is so you're saying it's
just not good at the negative
uh like
classifying the negative so that's why
it can't be used for the localization no
it's just that you train the system
you know you you you give it an image
and then you give it the same image
shifted and scaled and you tell it
that's the same image
so the system basically is trained to
eliminate the information about position
and size
so now
and now you want to use that oh yeah
like figure out where an object is and
what size is like a bounding box like to
be able to actually okay it can still
find it can still find the object in the
image it's just not very good at finding
the exact boundaries of that object
interesting
interesting which
you know that's an interesting sort of
philosophical question how important how
important is object localization anyway
we're like obsessed by measuring like
image segmentation
obsessed by measuring perfectly knowing
the boundaries of objects when
arguably
that's not
that essential to understanding what are
the contents of the scene
on the other hand i think evolutionarily
the first vision systems in animals were
basically all about localization very
little about recognition
and in the human brain you have two
separate pathways for
recognizing the nature of a scene an
object
and localizing objects so you use the
first pathway called a ventral pathway
for
you know telling what you're looking at
the other path for the dorsal pathway is
used for navigation for grasping for
everything else and you know basically a
lot of the things you need for survival
are
localization and detection
is similarity learning or contrast of
learning are these non-contrastive
methods the same as understanding
something
just because you know a distorted cat is
the same as a non-distorted cat does
that mean you understand
what it means to be a cat
to some extent i mean it's a superficial
understanding obviously but like what is
the ceiling of this method do you think
is this just one
trick on the path to
doing cell supervised learning can we go
yeah really really far
i think we can go really far so if we
figure out how to
uh use techniques of that type perhaps
very different but you know the
signature
to
train a system from from video to do
video prediction essentially
i think we'll have a path um you know
towards uh
you know i wouldn't say unlimited but
but a path towards some level of
uh
you know physical common sense in
machines and i also think that um
that
ability to learn how the world works
from a sort of high throughput channel
like like vision
is a necessary step towards uh sort of
real artificial intelligence in other
words i believe in ground intelligence i
don't think we can train a machine to be
intelligent purely from text
because i think the amount of
information about the world that's
contained in text is tiny compared to
what we need to know
so for example let's uh and you know
people have attempted to do this for for
30 years right the psych project and
things like that right of basically kind
of writing down all the facts that are
known and
hoping that some some sort of common
sense will emerge um i think it's
basically hopeless but let me take an
example you take an object
i i describe the situation to you i take
an object i put it on the table and i
push the table it's completely obvious
to you that the object will be pushed
with the table right because it's
sitting on it
there's no text in the world i believe
that explains this
and so
if you train a machine as powerful as it
could be you know your gpt 5000
or whatever it is it's never going to
learn about this
um that information is just not is not
present in any text
well the question like with the psyc
project the dream i think is to have
like
like 10 million
say facts like that
that give you a head start
like a parent guiding you
now we humans don't need a parent to
tell us that the table will move uh
sorry the smartphone will move with the
table
but
we get a lot of guidance in other ways
so it's possible that we can give it a
quick shortcut what about cat the guy
knows that
no but they evolved so
no they learn like us
the the sorry the physics of stuff
well
yeah so you're saying it's
uh
see you're putting a lot of intelligence
onto the nurture side not the nature yes
we seem to have um
you know there's a very inefficient
arguably process of evolution that got
us from bacteria to who we are today
started at the bottom now we're here so
true uh
the question is how okay so the question
is how fundamental is that the the
nature of the whole hardware
and then
is there any way to shortcut it if it's
fundamental if it's not if it's most of
intelligence most of the cool stuff
we've been talking about is mostly
nurture mostly trained we figure it out
by observing the world we can form that
uh big beautiful sexy background model
that you're talking about just by
sitting there
then okay then you need to then like
maybe
uh
it is all supervised learning all the
way down
so surprise learning site whatever it is
that makes uh you know human
intelligence different from other
animals which you know a lot of people
think is language and logical reasoning
and this kind of stuff
it cannot be that complicated because it
only popped up in the last million years
yeah
and
you know it it and it only involves you
know
less than one percent of our genome
might be which is the difference between
human genome and gyms or whatever
so uh
it can be that complicated you know it
can be that fundamental i mean the most
of the
so complicated stuff already exist in
cats and dogs and
you know certainly primates non-human
primates
yeah that little thing with humans might
be just uh something about social
interaction and ability to maintain
ideas across
like a collective of people
it's it sounds very dramatic and very
impressive but it probably isn't
mechanistically speaking it is but we're
not there yet like you know we we have i
mean this is number 634 you know in the
list of problems to solve
so basic physics of the world is is
number one what do you um
just a quick
tangent on data augmentation so a lot of
it is
hard-coded versus learned
do you have any intuition that maybe
there could be some weird data
augmentation
like generative type of data
augmentation like doing something weird
to images which then
improves the
the similarity learning process so not
just kind of dumb
simple distortions but
by you shaking your head just saying
that even simple distortions are enough
i think no i think that augmentation is
a temporary necessary evil
so what people are working on now is is
two things one is
uh the type of self-supervisioning
like trying to to translate the type of
cell suppressant people using language
translating these two images which is
basically denoting autoencoder method
right so you you take an image you you
block you mask some parts of it
and then you you train some giant neural
net to reconstruct the parts that you've
that are that are missing and
until very recently
there was no there was no working
methods for that uh all the autoencoder
type methods for images weren't
producing very good representation but
there's a paper now coming out of
the fair group in menlo park that
actually works very well so
that doesn't require the documentation
that requires only masking
okay only masking for images
uh
okay right so you mask part of the image
and you train a system which you know
in this case is a transformer because
you can you can
the transformer represents the image as
uh non-overlapping patches so it's easy
to mask patches and things like that
okay then my question transfers to that
problem the masking like why should the
mask be a square or rectangle so it
doesn't matter like you know i think
we're gonna come up probably in the
future with sort of uh
you know ways to mask that are is you
know kind of
random essentially well i mean they are
random already but no no but like
something that's challenging
like
optimally challenging so like i mean
maybe it's a metaphor that doesn't apply
but you're it seems like there's an data
augmentation or masking
there's an interactive element with it
like you're almost like playing with an
image
and like it's like the way we play with
an image in our minds no but it's like
dropout it's like boston machine
training you um
you know every every every time you see
a percept
you also
you you can you can perturb it in some
way and then uh the the principle of the
training procedure
is to minimize the difference of the
output of the representation
between the the clean version and the
corrupted version essentially right and
you you can do this in real time right
so you know what's the machine work like
this right you you you show a percept
and you tell the machine that's a good
combination of activities or your input
neurons
uh and then you either uh
let them
go their merry way without
clamping them to values or you only do
this with a subset yeah and what you're
doing is you're training the system so
that the
the stable state of the entire network
is the same regardless of whether it
sees the entire input or whether it is
only part of it
um you know the nozzling autoencoder
method is basically the same thing right
you you're you're training a system to
reproduce the input the complete inputs
and filling the blanks regardless of
which which parts are missing and that's
really the underlying principle and you
could imagine sort of a even in the
brain some sort of neural principle
where you know neurons gonna
oscillate right so they they take their
activity and then temporarily they kind
of shut off
to
you know force the rest of the system to
basically
reconstruct
the input without their help you know
and and and
i mean you could imagine you know you
know more or less biologically possible
processes
and i guess with this uh denoising
auto encoder and masking and data
augmentation you don't have to worry
about being super efficient
you can just
do as much as you want yeah and get
better over time
because i was thinking like you might
want to be clever about the way you do
all these procedures
you know but
that's only if it's somehow costly to do
every iteration but it's not really not
really
maybe
and then there is you know data
augmentation without explicit data
augmentation is data augmentation by
waiting which is you know the the sort
of video prediction
you're
observing a video clip observing the
you know the continuation of that video
clip and try you try to learn a
representation using those joint
embedding architectures in such a way
that the representation of the future
clip is easily predictable from the
representation of the of the observed
clip
do you think youtube has enough
raw data
from which to learn
how to be a cat
i think so
so the
the amount of data is not the constraint
no it would require some selection i
think
some
some selection of you know maybe the
right type of data you know down the
rabbit hole of just cat videos that
might you might need to watch some
lectures or something
no you wouldn't how meta would that be
if it like watches
lectures about intelligence and then
learns watches your lectures and nyu and
learns from that how to be intelligent
uh what's your uh do you find
multi-modal learning interesting we've
been talking about visual language like
combining those together maybe audio all
those kinds of things there's a lot of
things that i find interesting in the
short term but are not
addressing the important problem that i
think are really kind of the big
challenges so i think you know things
like multitask learning continual
learning
uh you know
adversarial issues i mean those have you
know great practical interests in the
relatively short term
uh possibly but i don't think they're
fundamental you know active learning
even to some extent reinforcement
learning i think
those things will
become either obsolete or
or useless or easy
once we figure out how to do
self-improvised representation learning
or or learning predictable models
and so i think that's what you know
the entire community should be focusing
on uh at least people are interested in
sort of fundamental questions or you
know really kind of pushing the envelope
of ai towards the next the next stage
but of course there's like a huge amount
of you know very interesting work to do
in sort of practical questions that have
you know short-term impact well you know
it's it's difficult to talk about the
temporal scale because
all of human civilization will
eventually be destroyed because the the
the sun will die out and even if elon
musk is successful multi-planetary
colonization across the galaxy uh
eventually
the entirety of it would just become
giant black holes and um
that's going to take a while though
so but but what i'm saying is then that
logic can be used to say it's all
meaningless
i'm saying all that to say that
multitask learning
[Music]
might be
your song you're calling it practical or
pragmatic or whatever
that might be the thing that achieves
something very akin to intelligence
while we're trying to solve the more
uh general problem of self-supervised
learning and background knowledge so the
reason i bring that up maybe one
way to ask that question i've been very
impressed by what tesla auto poly team
is doing i don't know if you got a
chance to glance at this particular one
example of
multi-task learning where they're
literally taking the problem
like i don't know charles darwin starts
studying animals they're studying
the problem of driving and asking okay
what are all the things you have to
perceive
and
the way they're solving it is one
there's an ontology where you're
bringing that to the table so you're
formulating a bunch of different tasks
it's like over a hundred tasks or
something like that then they're
involved in driving and then they're
deploying it and then getting data back
from people that run into trouble and
they're trying to figure out do we add
tasks do we like we focus on each
individual task separately sure in fact
half so the i would say i'll classify
andre carpathi's talk in two ways so one
was about doors
and the other one about how much image
net sucks
he kept going
back and forth on those two topics which
image that sucks meaning you can't just
use a single benchmark there's so like
you you have to have
like a giant suite of benchmarks to
understand how well your your system
actually i agree with him i mean he's uh
he's a very sensible guy
now
okay it's it's very clear that if you're
faced with a an engineering problem that
you need to solve in a relatively short
time particularly if you have it almost
breathing down your neck
you're going to have to take shortcuts
right you you
you might think about the the fact that
the the the right thing to do in the
long-term solution involves you know
some fancy self-supervisioning but you
have
you know you know almost reading on your
neck uh and you know this involves uh
you know human lives and so
you you have to
basically just do the systematic uh
engineering and you know
uh
fine tuning and refinements and trial
and error and and all that stuff um
there's nothing wrong with that that's
that's called engineering that's called
you know uh
putting technology out uh in the
in the world um and and you have to kind
of ironclad it before before you do this
you know
so much for you know grand grand ideas
and principles
um
but you know i'm placing myself sort of
you know some
you know upstream of this queen or quite
a bit of stream of this your plato think
about platonic forms you're you're
platonic because eventually
i want that stuff to get used but uh
it's okay if it takes five or ten years
for the community to realize this is the
right thing to do i've i've done this
before it's been the case before that
you know i've made that case i mean if
you look back in the mid-2000s for
example and you ask yourself the
question okay i want to recognize cars
or faces or whatever
you know i can use convolutional net so
i can use a more conventional
kind of computer vision techniques you
know using uh interest point detectors
or swift density features and you know
sticking an svm on top at that time the
data sets were so small that
those
methods that use more hand engineering
worked better than companies there was
just not enough data for comnets and
contests were were a little a little
slow with the kind of hardware that was
available at the time
and there was a c change when uh
basically when you know
data sets become bigger and and gpus
became available that that's what
you know those
two of the main factors that basically
made people change their change their
mind
and you can
you can look at the history of
like all sub-branches of ai or pattern
recognition
and there's a similar trajectory
followed by techniques where people
start by you know engineering the hell
out of it
um you know
be it
optical character recognition
speech recognition
computer vision like image recognition
in general uh natural language
understanding like you know translation
things like that right you start to
engineer the hell out of it
um you start to acquire all knowledge
the prior knowledge you know about image
formation about you know the shape of
characters about you know morphological
operations about like feature extraction
fourier transforms
you know very quickly moments you know
whatever right people have come up with
thousands of ways of representing images
so that they could be easily uh
classified afterwards same for speech
recognition right there is you know two
decades for people to figure out a good
front end uh to pre-process uh
speech signals so that you know the
information about what is being said is
preserved but most of the information
about the identity of the speaker is
gone um
you know kestrel coefficients or
whatever right um and same for for text
right uh you do need entity recognition
and you parse and you you you do tagging
of
of of the parts of speech and you know
you do this sort of tree representation
of clauses and all that stuff right
before you can do anything
so
that's how it starts right just engineer
the hell out of it and then you start
having data
and maybe you have more powerful
computers maybe you know something about
statistical learning so you start using
machine learning and it's usually a
small sliver on top of your kind of
handcrafted system where you know you
extract features by hand okay and now
you know nowadays the standard way of
doing this is that you train the entire
thing end to end with the deep learning
system and it learns its own features
and
and you know speech recognition systems
nowadays uh ocr systems are completely
end-to-end it's uh you know it's some
giant neural net that takes raw
waveforms
and produces a sequence of characters
coming out and it's just a huge neural
net right there's no you know minecraft
model there's no language model that is
explicit other than you know something
that's ingrained in the in the sort of
neural language model if you want same
for translation same for all kinds of
stuff so you see this
continuous evolution
from
you know less and less hand crafting and
more and more learning
um
and uh
i i think
it's true in biology as well
so i mean we might disagree about this
maybe not uh in this one little piece at
the end you mentioned active learning
it feels like active learning which is
the selection of data and also the
interactivity needs to be part of this
giant neural network you cannot just be
an observer to do self-supervised
learning you have to well
i don't self supervise learning is just
a word but i would whatever this giant
stack of a neural network that's
automatically learning it feels my
intuition is
that
you have to have a system whether it's a
physical robot or a digital robot that's
interacting with the world
and doing so in a flawed way and
improving over time
in order to to form the self-supervised
learning
well you can't just give it a giant sea
of data okay i agree and i disagree okay
i agree in the sense that i think uh
i agree i agree in two ways the first
the first way i agree is that if you
want uh
and you certainly need a causal model of
the world that allows you to predict the
consequences of your actions
to train that model you need to take
actions right you need to be able to act
in a world and see the effect
for you to be to learn causal models of
the world well so that's not that's not
obvious because you can observe others
you can observe others and you can infer
that they're similar to you and then you
can learn from that yeah but then you
have to kind of hardwire that part right
you know mirror neurons and all that
stuff right so um
and it's not clear to me how you would
do this in a machine so
um
so i think the the action part would be
necessary for having causal models of of
the world
the second reason it may be
necessary or at least more efficient is
that
uh
active learning basically you know goes
for the jiggler of what you're what you
don't know right
is this you know obvious
areas of uncertainty
uh about your your world and about the
how the world behaves
and
you can resolve this uncertainty by
systematic exploration of that part that
you don't you don't know and if you know
that you don't know then you know it
makes you curious you kind of look into
situations that
and uh you know across the animal uh
world
different species are different levels
of curiosity right
yeah depending on how they're built
right so
you know cats and rats are incredibly
curious uh dogs not so much i mean less
yeah so it could be useful to have that
kind of curiosity so it'd be useful but
curiosity just makes the process faster
it doesn't make the process exist
the
so what process what learning process
is it that
active learning makes more efficient
and i'm asking that first question uh
you know
you know we haven't answered that
question yet so you know i worry about
active learning once this question is so
it's the more fundamental question to
ask
and if active learning or
interaction
increases the efficiency of the learning
see sometimes
it becomes very different if the
increase is several orders of magnitude
right like that's true
but fundamentally still the same thing
and building up the intuition about how
to
in a self-supervised way to construct
background models efficient or
inefficient
is um is the core problem
what do you think about yoshi banjos
talking about consciousness
and all of these kinds of concepts okay
um
i don't know what consciousness is
but uh
it's a good opener
and to some extent a lot of the things
that are said about consciousness remind
me of
the questions people were asking
themselves in the 18th century or 17th
century when they discovered that
uh you know how the eye works and the
fact that the image at the back of the
eye was
upside down
right because you have a lens and and so
on your retina the image that forms is
an image of the world but it's upside
down how is it that you see right side
up
and you know with what we know today in
science you know we realize this
question doesn't make any sense
or or is kind of ridiculous in some way
right so i think a lot of what is said
about consciousness is of that nature
now that said there's a lot of really
smart people that uh for whom i have a
lot of respect who are talking about
this topic people like david chalmers
who is the colleague of mine at nyu
i have kind of a
unorthodox folk
speculative
hypothesis about consciousness so we're
talking about this audio world model and
uh i think you know our entire
prefrontal cortex basically is
uh the engine for our world model
but when we are
attending at a particular situation
we're focused on that situation we
basically cannot attend to anything else
and that
seems to suggest
that we basically have only one
world model engine in our pre-photo
cortex
that engine is configurable to the
situation at hand so we are building a
box out of wood or we are you know
driving uh
down the highway playing chess we we
basically have uh a single model of the
world that we configure into the
situation at hand
which is why we can only attend to one
task at a time
now if there is a task that we do
repeatedly
it it goes from the sort of deliberate
reasoning using model of the world and
prediction and perhaps something like
model predictive control which i was
talking about earlier
to something that is more subconscious
that becomes automatic so i don't know
if you've ever played against a chess
grandmaster
uh you know i get wiped out in you know
10 flies right
and you know i have to think about my
move for
you know like 15 minutes
uh and the person in front of me the
grandmaster you know would just like
react within seconds right
you know he doesn't need to
think about it that's become part of the
subconscious because you know it's
basically just
pattern recognition at this point
um
same you know you the first few hours
you drive a car you're really attentive
you can't do anything else and then
after 20-30 hours of practice 50 hours
you know a subconscious you can talk to
the person next to you you know things
like that right
unless the situation becomes
unpredictable and then you have to stop
talking
so that suggests you only have one model
in your head
and
it might suggest the idea that
consciousness basically is the module
that configures this world model of
yours you know you need to have some
sort of
executive kind of overseer that
configures your word model for the
situation at hand
and that that leads to kind of the
really curious concept that
consciousness is not a consequence of
the power of our minds but of the
limitation of our brains
but because we have only one world model
we have to be conscious if we had as
many role models as
there are situations we encounter then
we could do all of them simultaneously
and we wouldn't need this sort of
executive control that we call
consciousness
yeah interesting and somehow maybe that
executive controller
i mean the the hard problem of
consciousness there's some kind of
chemicals in biology that's creating a
feeling
like it feels to experience some of
these things
that's kind of like the hard question is
what the heck is that and why is that
useful maybe the more pragmatic question
why is it useful to feel like
this is really you
experiencing this versus just like
information
being processed
um it could be just a very nice side
effect of um
of the way we evolved that's just very
useful to
to uh
feel a sense of uh ownership to the
decisions you make to the perceptions
you make to the model you're trying to
maintain like you own this thing
and it's the only one you got and if you
lose it it's gonna really suck and so
you should really send the brain some
signals about it
what ideas do you believe might be true
that most or at least many people
disagree with you with
let's say in the space of machine
learning
well it depends who you talk about but
i think
so certainly there is uh
a bunch of people who are nativists
right who think that a lot of the basic
things about the world are kind of
hardwired in our you know minds
things like you know the world is
three-dimensional for example is that
hardwired things like uh you know object
permanence is something that we learn uh
you know before the age of three months
or so or are we born with it and there
are you know very disa you know
white disagreement among the you know
cognitive scientists
for this
i think those things are actually very
simple to learn
um
you know is it the case that the
oriented edge detectors in v1 are
learned or are they hardwired i think
they are learned they might be learned
before both because it's really easy to
generate signals from the retina that
actually will train edge detectors so
um and again those are
things that can be learned within
minutes of uh opening your eyes right i
mean
you know since the 1990s we have
algorithms that can learn oriented
detectors completely unsupervised with
the equivalent of a few minutes of real
time so
uh so those things have to be learned
um and there's also those you know mit
experiments where you kind of
plug the
optical nerve on the auditory cortex of
a baby ferret right and that auditory
cortex becomes a visual cortex
essentially
so you know clearly
there's running taking place there
so you know i think a lot of what people
think are so basic that they need to be
hardwired
i think a lot of those things are
learned because they are easy to learn
jesus so you put a lot of
value in the power of learning what kind
of things do you suspect might not be
learned
is there something that could not be
learned
so your intrinsic drives are not learned
they they there are the things that you
know make humans uh
human or make you know
cats different from dogs right it's the
the basic drives that are kind of
hard-wired in our basal ganglia
i mean there are people who are working
on on this kind of stuff that's called
intrinsic motivation in the context of
reinforcement learning um so these are
objective functions where the reward
doesn't come from the external world
it's computed by your own brain your own
brain computes
whether you're happy or not right it
measures your degree of uh
comfort or in comfort
and
and because it's your brain computing
this presumably knows also how to
estimate gradients of this right so
um
so it's easier to to learn when your
objective is is intrinsic
so that has to be hardwired
the critic that makes long-term
prediction of the outcome which is the
eventual
result of this that's learned
and perception is learned and your model
of the world is learned but let me take
take an example of you know why the
critic i mean example of how the critic
might be learned right if i uh if i come
to you um
you know i reach across the table and i
pinch your arm right complete surprise
for you
you would not have expected this i was
expecting that the whole time but yes
right let's say for the sake of the
story yes
um okay your visual ganglia is going to
light up because it's going to hurt
right
and now your model of the world includes
the fact that i may pinch you if i
approach my uh
my uh don't trust humans right
my hand to your arm so if i try again
you're gonna recoil and that's your
critic
uh your predictive
you know your predictor of your uh
ultimate pain uh
uh
system
that predicts that something bad is
going to happen when you recoil right to
avoid it so even that can be learned
that is drawing definitely this is what
allows you also to uh you know define
some goals right so
um the fact that you know you're a
school child you wake up in the morning
and you go to school and you know
it's not because you necessarily like
waking up early and going to school but
you know that there is a long-term
objective you're trying to optimize so
ernest becker i'm not sure if you're
familiar with the philosopher he wrote
the book denial of death and his idea is
that one of the core motivations of
human beings is our terror of death our
fear of death
that's what makes us unique from cats
cats are just surviving they do not have
a
deep
under like
cognizance
introspection that
over the horizon is the end
and he says that i mean there's a terror
management theory that just all these
psychological experiments that show
the basically
this idea that
all of human civilization everything we
create is kind of trying to forget if
even for a brief moment that we're going
to die
when when do you think humans
understand that they're going to die is
it learned early on
also like
i don't know at what point i mean it's a
it's a question like you know at what
point do you realize that you know what
death really is and i think most people
don't actually realize what death is
right i mean most people believe that
you go to heaven or something right well
so
to push back on that what ernest becker
says and um sheldon solomon all of those
folks
and i find those ideas a little bit
compelling is that there is moments in
life early in life a lot of this fun
happens early in life
when you are
uh when you do deeply experience the
terror of this realization and all the
things you think about about religion
all those kinds of things that we kind
of think about more like teenage years
and later
we're talking about way earlier no it's
like seven or eight years or something
like that yeah you realize
holy crap
this is uh like the mystery the terror
like it's almost like you're a little
prey a little baby deer sitting in the
darkness of the jungle of the woods
looking all around you the darkness full
of terror i mean that's that realization
says okay i'm gonna go go back in the
comfort of my mind where there's a well
there is a deep meaning where there's a
maybe like pretend i'm immortal however
way
however kind of idea i can construct to
help me understand that i'm immortal
religion helps with that you can you can
delude yourself in all kinds of ways
like lose yourself in the busyness of
each day have little goals in mind all
those kinds of things to think that it's
going to go on forever and you kind of
know you're going to die yeah and it's
going to be sad but you don't really
understand that you're going to die and
so that's that's their idea and if i
find that compelling
because it does seem to be a core unique
aspect of human nature that we were able
to think that we're going we're able to
really understand
that this life is finite
that seems important
there's a bunch of different things
there so first of all i don't think
there is a qualitative difference
between between us and cats in the term
i think the difference is that we just
have a better long-term
ability to
predict you know in the long term and so
we have a better understanding of how
the world works so we have better
understanding of you know finance of
life and things like that so we have a
better planning engine than cats yeah
okay um but what's the motivation for
for planning well i think it's just a
side effect of the fact that we have
just a better planning engine because it
makes us uh as i said you know the
essence of intelligence is the ability
to predict and so the because we're
smarter
as a side effect we also have this
ability to kind of make predictions
about our own
future existence or lack thereof okay
you say religion helps with that i think
religion hurts actually
it makes people worry about like you
know what's going to happen after their
death etc
if you believe that you know
you just don't exist after that so like
you know it solves completely the
problem at least you're saying if you
don't believe in god you don't worry
about what happens after death yeah
i don't know why you worry about the
about
you know this life because that's the
only one you have
i think it's well i don't i don't know
if i were to say what ernest becker says
and i said i agree with him more
uh than not is um
you do deeply worry uh if you if you
believe there's no god there's still a
deep worry like of the mystery of it all
like how does that make any sense that
it just ends i don't think we can
truly understand
that this ride i mean so much of our
life the consciousness the ego
is uh invested in this in this being and
then
science keeps bringing humanity down
from its pedestal
and yeah that's another another example
of it that's wonderful but for us
individual humans we don't like to be
brought down from a pedestal
like
but see you're fine with it because well
so what ernest becker would say is
you're fine with it because that's just
a more peaceful existence for you but
you're not really fine you're hiding
from in fact some of the people that
experience the deepest trauma
uh that
earlier in life
they often before they seek extensive
therapy will say i'm fine it's like when
you talk to people who are truly angry
how are you doing i'm fine
the question is what's going on
now i had a near death experience i had
a very bad uh motorbike accident when i
was 17. so
but that didn't have any impact on
my
reflection on that topic so i'm
basically just playing a bit of a
devil's advocate pushing back and
wondering
is it truly possible to accept death and
the flip side that's more interesting i
think for ai and
robotics is how important is it to have
this as one of the suite of motivations
is to
not just avoid
falling off the roof or something like
that but
ponder
the
the end of the ride
if you listen to the stoics
it's uh it's a great motivator
it adds a sense of urgency so maybe to
truly fear death or be cognizant of it
might give
a deeper meaning and urgency to the
moment to live
fully
well
maybe i don't disagree with that uh i
mean i think what motivates me here is
uh
you know knowing more about about human
nature i mean i think uh human nature
and human intelligence is a big mystery
it's a scientific mystery
uh in addition to you know philosophical
and etc but you know i'm a true believer
in science so
um
and and and i do have kind of a belief
that for complex systems like like the
brain on the mind the the way to
understand it is try to reproduce it
with you know artifacts that you build
because you know what's essential to it
when you try to build it you know the
same way
i've used this analogy before with you i
believe um the same way we only started
to understand uh
aerodynamics when we started building
airplanes and that helped us understand
how birds fly
you know so i think there's kind of a
similar process here where
we don't have a theory of a full theory
of intelligence
but building you know intelligent
artifacts will help us perhaps develop
some
you know underlying theory that
encompasses not just artificial
implements but also
human and biological intelligence in
general so you're an interesting person
to ask this question about
sort of all kinds of different other
intelligent entities
or intelligences
what are your thoughts about kind of
like the touring or the chinese room
question
if we create an ai system that exhibits
a lot of properties of intelligence and
consciousness
how comfortable are you thinking of that
entity as intelligent or conscious
so you're trying to build now systems
that have intelligence and there's
metrics about their performance but that
metric
is
external
okay so how are you are you okay calling
a thing intelligent are you going to be
like most humans
and be uh
once again unhappy to be brought down
from a pedestal of consciousness slash
intelligence no i'm i'll be very happy
to
understand
more about human nature human mind and
human intelligence
through the construction of machines
that
have similar abilities and
if a consequence of this is to bring
down humanity one notch down from
it's already okay
i'm just fine with it that's just the
reality of life
um so i'm fine with that now you were
asking me about things that uh opinions
i have that a lot of people may disagree
with
i think
uh
if we think about the design of an
autonomous intelligence system so
assuming that we are somewhat successful
at some at some level
of getting machines to learn models of
the world predicting models of the world
we have we build intrinsic motivation
objective functions to drive the
behavior of that system
the system also has perception modules
that allows it to estimate the state of
the world and then have some way of
figuring out the sequence of actions
that you know to optimize a particular
objective
if it has a critic of the type that was
describing before the thing that makes
you recall your arm the second time i
tried to pinch you
um
intelligent autonomous machine will have
emotions
i think emotions are an integral part of
autonomous intelligence
if you have an intelligent system
that is driven by
intrinsic motivation by objectives
if it has
a critic that allows you to predict in
advance whether the outcome of a
of a situation is going to be good or
bad is going to have emotions it's going
to have fear yes
when it predicts that the outcome is
gonna is gonna be bad
and and something to avoid is gonna have
elation when it predicts it's gonna be
good
um uh if it has drives to
relate with humans um you know in some
ways the way humans have
um
you know it's it's gonna be social right
and so it's gonna have emotions about
attachment and and things of that type
so
um so i think uh you know the the sort
of
sci-fi
thing where you know you see commander
data like having an emotion chip that
you can turn off right
i think that's ridiculous
so i mean here's the difficult
philosophical
social question
do you think there will be a time
like a civil rights movement for robots
where
um okay forget the movement but a
discussion like the supreme court
that particular kinds of robots
you know particular kinds of systems
um deserve the same rights as humans
because they can suffer
just as humans can
all those kinds of things
well perhaps perhaps not like imagine
that humans were
that that you could uh
you know die and be restored like you
know you could be sort of you know be 3d
reprinted and you know your brain could
be reconstructed in its finest details
our ideas of rights will change in that
case
if you can always just
there's always a backup you could always
restore maybe like the importance of
murder will go down one notch that's
right but also the uh
your your
you know desire to do dangerous things
like you know
you know doing skydiving or or you know
or or you know race car driving
you know car racing all that kind of
stuff you know would probably increase
or or you know airplane aerobatics or
that kind of stuff right yeah it would
be fine to do a lot of those things or
explore
you know dangerous areas and things like
that it would kind of change your
relationship so
now it's very likely that robots would
be like that because you know they'll be
based on perhaps technology that is
somewhat similar to
today's technology and you can you can
always have a backup
so it's possible
i don't know if you like video games but
there's a there's a game called diablo
and um oh my my sons are huge fans of
this yes uh
and in fact they made a game that's
inspired by it
awesome
like built a game my three sons have a
game design studio between them yeah
that's awesome they came out with a game
like it just came out nice again last
year no this was last year earlier about
a year ago that's awesome but so in
diablo there's a something called
hardcore mode which if you die there's
no
you're gone right that's it and so it's
possible with ai systems
for them to be able to operate
successfully and for us to treat them in
a certain way because they have to be
integrated in human society
they have to be able to die no copies
allowed in fact copying is illegal it's
possible with humans as well like
cloning will be illegal even what's
possible because
cloning is not copying right i mean you
don't reproduce the
the mind of the person and like
experience right it's just a delay twin
so
but then it's what we were talking about
with computers that you'll be able to
copy you right you'll be able to
perfectly save pickle
the the
the mind state and
it's possible that that would be illegal
because
that goes against um
that will destroy the motivations of the
system
okay so let's say you you have a
domestic robot okay sometime in the
future yes
and uh the domestic robot you know comes
to you kind of somewhat pre-trained you
know it can do a bunch of things yes but
it has a particular personality that
makes it slightly different from the
other robots because that makes them
more interesting and then because it's
you know it's live with you for five
years you've you've grown some
attachment to it and vice versa and it's
learned a lot about you
or maybe it's not a household robot
maybe it's uh maybe it's a virtual
assistant that lives in your you know
augmented reality glasses or whatever
right
uh you know the horror movie type thing
right
um
and that system to some extent
the the
intelligence in that system
is a bit like your child or maybe your
phd student in a sense that
there's a lot of you in that in that
machine now right yeah and so
if it were a living thing
you would do this
for free if you want right if it's your
child your child can you know then
live his or her own life and you know
the fact that they learn stuff from you
doesn't mean that you have any ownership
of it right yeah but if it's a robot
that you've trained perhaps you have
some uh yeah intellectual property claim
about intellectual property oh i thought
you meant like uh permanent value in the
sense this part of you is in well there
is permanent value right so you would
lose a lot if that robot were to be
destroyed and you you had no backup you
would lose a lot you know you a lot of
investment you know kind of like a
uh you know a person dying you know um
that that a friend of a friend of you
was dying or or a co-worker or something
like that um
but also uh you have like
intellectual property rights in the
sense that that
that system is fine-tuned to your
particular existence so that's now a
very unique instantiation of that
original background model whatever it
was that arrived
and then there are issues of privacy
right because now
imagine that that robot has its own kind
of volition and decides to work from
someone else yes or kind of you know
thinks
life with you is sort of untenable or
whatever right um
now all the things that that system
learned from you
uh
you know how
can you like you know delete all the
personal information that that system
knows about you yeah
i mean that would be kind of an ethical
question like you know can you erase the
the mind of a of a intelligent robot
uh to protect your your privacy yeah you
can't do this with humans you can ask
them to shut up but that you don't have
complete power over them can't erase
humans yeah it's the problem with
relationships you know that you break up
you can't you can't erase the other
human
with robots i think it'll have to be the
same thing with robots that that risk
that there has to be um
some
risk to our interactions to truly
experience them deeply it feels like so
you have to be able to lose your robot
friend
and that robot friend to go tweeting
about how much of an [ __ ] you are but
then are you allowed to you know murder
the robot to protect your private
information yeah probably decides to
leave i have the situation that for
robots with with certain
like it's almost like uh regulation if
you declare your robot to be
let's call it sentient or something like
that like this this robot is designed
for human interaction then you're not
allowed to murder these robots it's the
same as murdering other humans well but
what about you do a backup of the robot
you do preserve on the on on a hard
drive or the equivalent in the future
that might be illegal just like it's
like
priority uh piracy is illegal but it's
your own it's your own robot right but
you can't you don't but then but then
you can wipe out
his brain so the this robot doesn't know
anything about you anymore but you still
have
technically a certain existence because
you backed it up and then there'll be
these great speeches at the supreme
court by saying oh sure you can erase
the mind of the robot just like you can
erase the mind of a human we both can
suffer there'll be some epic like obama
type character with a speech that we we
like the robots and the humans are the
same
we can both suffer we can both hope
we can both
all those all those kinds of things
raise families all that kind of stuff
it's it's uh interesting for these just
like you said emotion seems to be a
fascinatingly powerful aspect of human
human interaction human robot
interaction and if they're able to
exhibit emotions
at the end of the day that's probably
going to
have us deeply consider
human rights like what we value in
humans what we value in other animals
that's why robots and ai is great it
makes us ask uh really good questions
the hard questions yeah but
you ask about you asked about the
chinese room type argument you know is
it real if it looks real yeah i think
the chinese room argument is the
ridiculous one so
so so for people who don't know chinese
room is
uh you ca you can i don't even know how
to formulate it well but basically
you can mimic the behavior of an
intelligent system by just following a
giant algorithm code book that tells you
exactly how to respond in exactly each
case but is that really intelligent it's
like a giant lookup table when this
person says this you answer this when
this person says this you answer this
and
if you understand how that works you
have this giant nearly infinite lookup
table is that really intelligence
because intelligence seems to be
a mechanism that's much more interesting
and complex than this lookup table i
don't think so so the i mean the real
question comes down to
do you think
uh
you know you can you can mechanize uh
intelligence in some way even if that
involves uh learning
and the answer is of course yes there's
no question
there's a second question then which is
uh assuming you can uh reproduce
intelligence in sort of different
hardware than biological hardware you
know like computers
uh
can you
you know
match uh human intelligence in
all the domains in which
humans are intelligent
is it possible right so that's the
hypothesis of a strong ai the answer to
this
in my opinion is unqualified yes this
will swell happen at some point there's
no question that
machines at some point will become more
intelligent than humans in all domains
where humans are intelligent this is not
for tomorrow it's going to take a long
time regardless of what you know
elon and others have claimed or believed
this is a lot a lot harder than many of
many of those guys think it is
and many of those guys who thought it
was simpler than that years you know
five years ago now i think it's hard
because it's been five years and they
realize it's it's gonna take a lot
longer
that includes a bunch of people deepmind
for example but um oh interesting i
haven't actually uh touched base with
the deepmind folks but some of it elon
or
uh democracy i mean sometimes
your role you have to kind of
create deadlines that are nearer than
farther away yeah to kind of create an
urgency because you know you have to
believe the impossible as possible in
order to accomplish it and there's of
course a flip side to that coin but it's
it's a weird
you can't be too cynical if you want to
get something done absolutely i i agree
with that but um
i mean you have to inspire people right
to work on certain ambitious things
um
so you know it's it's uh it's certainly
a lot harder than we believe but there's
no question in my mind that this will
this will happen and now you know people
are kind of worried about what does that
mean
for humans
they are going to be brought down from
their pedestal you know a bunch of
notches
with that and uh
you know
is that going to be good or bad i mean
it's just going to give more power right
it's an amplifier for human intelligence
really so speaking of doing cool
ambitious things
fair
the facebook ai research group has
recently celebrated its 8th birthday
or
maybe you can correct me on that
looking back what has been
the successes the failures the lessons
learned from the eight years affair and
maybe you can also give context of where
does
the newly minted meta ai
fit into how does it relate to fare
right so let me tell you a little bit
about the organization of all this uh uh
yeah fair was created almost exactly
eight years ago uh it wasn't called fair
yet it took that name a few a few months
later
and at the time i joined facebook there
was a group called the ai group that had
about 12
engineers and a few science a few
scientists like you know ten engineers
and two scientists or something like
that
i ran it for three and a half years as a
director
you know hired the first few scientists
and kind of set up the culture and
organized it you know explain to the
facebook leadership what what
fundamental research was about and how
it can work within uh
industry and how it needs to be open and
everything
and
i think it's been an unqualified success
in the sense that
fair has simultaneously produced
you know top-level research
and advanced the science and the
technology provided tools open source
tools like pytorch and many others
but at the same time has had a direct or
mostly indirect impact
on
facebook at the time now meta
in the sense that a lot of systems
that are
that meta is built around
now are
are based on
research projects that
started at at fair so if you were to
take out you know deep learning out of
uh
facebook services now and and meta more
generally uh i mean the
company would literally crumble i mean
it's completely built around
around ai these days and it's really
essential to the operations
so what happened after three and a half
years is that
i changed role i became chief scientist
so i'm i'm not doing day-to-day
management of
affair anymore
i'm more of a kind of
you know think about strategy and things
like that and and i carry my i conduct
my own research i've you know my own
kind of research group working on star
supervision and things like this which i
didn't have time to do when i was
director
so now uh fair is run by uh joel pineau
and antoine board
together because fair is kind of split
in two now there's something called fair
labs which is sort of
bottom-up scientist-driven research and
fair excel which is slightly more
organized for bigger projects that
require
a little more kind of focus and more
engineering support and things like that
so joelle needs fair lab and antoine
bourne leads very where are they located
uh it's always delocalized all over
um so there's no question that the
leadership
of the company
believes that
this was a very worthwhile
investment and what that means is that
uh
it's it's there for the long run
right so there is uh
if you if you want to talk in these
terms which i don't like there's a
there's a business model if you want
where where
uh fair despite being a very fundamental
research lab brings a lot of value to
the company either mostly indirectly
through other groups
now what happened three and a half years
ago when i stepped down is was also the
creation of facebook ai which was
basically a larger organization that
covers fare so fair is included in it
but also has other organizations that
are
uh
focused on
applied research or advanced development
of ai technology that is more you know
focused on the
products of the company so less emphasis
on fundamental research less fundamental
but it's still research i mean there's a
lot of papers coming out of those
organizations and
uh
people are awesome awesome and you know
wonderful to interact with and but it
serves uh as kind of uh
a way to you kind of scale up
if you want um
sort of ai technology which you know may
be very experimental and and sort of lab
prototypes into things that are usable
so fair is a subset of meta ai it's fair
become like kfc it it'll just keep the f
nobody cares what the f stands for
we'll know
soon enough uh by uh probably probably
by the end of the
of 2021 this is not a giant change mayor
fair well mayor doesn't sound too good
but
you know the the brand people are kind
of deciding on this
and they've been hesitating for for a
while now and they you know they tell us
they're going to come up with an answer
as to whether fair is going to change
name or whether we're going to change
just the meaning of the f
oh that's a good call i would keep fair
and change the meaning of the f that
would be my preference you know i would
tend i would turn the f into fundamental
oh that's what i researched oh that's
really good yeah then meta ai so this
would be fair affair yeah but you know
people will call it fair right yeah
exactly i like it and now meta ai uh
is part of
the
reality lab so you know
meta now
the new facebook is called meta and it's
kind of
divided into
you know
facebook instagram
whatsapp
and reality lab and reality lab is about
you know ar vr
uh
you know telepresence communication part
uh technology and stuff like that that's
kind of the
you can think of it as the sort of
a combination of um
sort of new products and and technology
part of uh
of uh meta is that where the touch
sensing for robots i saw that you were
posting about that's that's what i
touched on for robotics party fair
actually that's that's it oh it is okay
yeah this is also the no but there is
the the other way the
the haptic glove right yes that has like
that's more reality that's that's
reality lab
research
i have to have research but by the way
the touch sensors are super interesting
uh like integrating that modality into
the whole
uh sensing uh suite is very interesting
so
uh
what do you think about the metaverse
what do you think about this whole
uh this whole kind of expansion of the
view of the role of facebook and meta in
the world well i made a verse really
should be thought of as the next step in
the internet right sort of
trying to
kind of you know make the experience
more compelling
of you know being
connected either with other people or
with content
and you know we are
evolved and trained to
evolve in you know 3d environments where
uh you know we can see other people we
can talk to them when when we're near
them or
you know and other people are far away
can hear us you know things like that
right so it it there's a lot of social
conventions that exist in the real world
that we can try to transpose now what is
going to be eventually the
the uh how compelling is it going to be
like our you know uh is it going to be
the case that people are going to be
willing to
do this if they have to wear you know a
huge pair of goggles all day
maybe not right but then again if the
experience is sufficiently compelling
maybe so or if the device that you have
to wear is just basically a pair of
glasses you know technology makes
sufficient progress for that
um you know ar is a much easier
concept to grasp that you're going to
have you know augmented reality glasses
that
basically contain some sort of you know
virtual assistant that can help you in
your daily lives but at the same time
with the ar you have to contend with
reality with vr you can completely
detach yourself from reality so it gives
you freedom it might be easier to design
worlds in in vr
yeah but you you can imagine how you
know the metaverse being
a mix a mix right or or like you can
have objects that exist in the metaverse
that you know pop up on top of the real
world or only exist in virtual reality
okay let me ask the hard question
oh because all of this was easy so this
was easy uh
the facebook now meta the social network
has been painted by the media as a net
negative for society even destructive
and evil at times
you've pushed back against this
defending facebook can you explain your
defense
yeah so the the description the company
that is being described in the
in some media
uh is not the company we know when we
work inside
and you know
it could be claimed that
a lot of employees are uninformed about
what really goes on in the company but
you know i'm a vice president
i mean i have a pretty good vision of
what goes on you know i don't know
everything obviously i'm not involved in
in everything but
certainly not in decision about like you
know content moderation or anything like
this but
but i have you know some decent vision
of what goes on
and this evil that is being described i
just don't see it
and then you know i think there is an
easy story
to buy
which is that you know all the bad
things in the in the world and you know
the the reason your friend believe crazy
stuff
um you know there's an easy scapegoat
right in the
uh in in in social media in general uh
facebook in particular
but you have to look at the data like is
it the case
that uh facebook for example uh
polarizes people politically
um are there academic studies that show
this
is it the case that uh you know
teenagers uh
think of themselves less if they use
instagram more
is it the case that uh
you know
people get more riled up against
you know opposite sides in a in a debate
or political opinion if they if they are
more on facebook or if they are less
and
study after study
show that none of this is true
this is independent studies by academic
they're not funded by facebook or meta
um you know study by stanford by some of
my colleagues at nyu actually with whom
i have no connection
um you know there's a study recently
they
they paid people i think it was in um
in in the former yugoslavia i'm not
exactly sure in what what part but they
paid people to not use facebook for a
while in the
period
before the anniversary of the
serenity
massacres right so you know people get
riled up like should you know should we
have
a celebration i mean a memorial kind of
celebration for it or not so they paid a
bunch of people to not use facebook for
a few weeks
it turns out that
those people ended up being more
polarized than they were at the
beginning and the people who were more
on facebook were less polarized
there's a study you know from stanford
of uh
economists at stanford that
tried to identify the causes of uh
increasing polarization in the u.s
and it's been going on for 40 years
before you know mark zuckerberg was born
yeah uh continuously
and um and uh so if there is a cause
it's not
facebook or social media so you could
say social media just accelerated but no
i mean it's basically a continuous
uh evolution by some measure of
polarization in the us and then you
compare this with other countries like
uh
the the west half of germany because you
can't go 40 years in east eastside or
denmark or or other countries
and they use facebook just as much and
they're not getting more polarized
they're getting less polarized so if you
want to look for you know a causal
relationship there
you can find a scapegoat but you can't
find the cause now if you want to fix
the problem you have to find the right
cause and what rise me up is that people
now are
accusing facebook of bad deeds that are
done by others and those others are
we're not doing anything about them
and by the way those others include
the owner of the wall street journal in
which all of those papers were published
so i should mention that i'm talking to
shrek mike schrepp for on this podcast
and also mark zuckerberg and probably
these conversations you can have with
them
because it's very interesting to me even
if facebook has
some measurable negative effect
you can't just consider that in
isolation you have to consider about all
the positive ways that it connects us so
like every technology there's people
it's that question you can't just say
like
uh there's an increase in division
yes probably google search engine has
created increase in division we have to
consider about how much information it
brought to the world like i'm sure
wikipedia created more division if you
just look at the division we have to
look at the full context of the world
and didn't make a better world yeah the
printing press has created more
differences right exactly
so you know when the
printing press was invented uh the first
books that were that were printed were
things like the bible and that allowed
people to read the bible by themselves
not get the message uniquely from
priests in europe
and they created you know the protest
movement and 200 years of religious
persecution and wars
so that's a bad side effect of the
printing press you know social networks
aren't being nearly as bad as the
printing press but nobody would say that
printing price was a bad idea
yeah a lot of it's perception and
there's a lot of different incentives
operating here um maybe a quick comment
since you're one of the top leaders at
facebook and at meta sorry that's in the
tech space
i'm sure facebook involves a lot of
incredible technological uh challenges
that need to be solved a lot of it
probably is on the computer
infrastructure the hardware the i mean
it's just a huge amount
maybe can you give me context about
how much of shrek's life
is ai and how much of it is low level
compute how much of it is
flying all around doing business stuff
and the same with zuckerberg mark
zuckerberg they really focus on ai i
mean certainly uh
in the uh
in the run-up of the creation affair and
for
you know at least a year after that if
not more
mark was was very very much focused on
on ai and was spending quite a lot of
effort um on it and that's his style
when he gets interested in something he
reads everything about it
you know he read some of my papers for
example before he joined um
and uh so he he learned a lot about it
like notes
right
and uh uh you know schwepp
was really into it also i mean tripe is
really kind of
um
you know has
something i've tried to preserve also
despite my uh not so young age which is
a sense of wonder about science and
technology and he certainly certainly
has that um he's also a wonderful person
i mean in terms of
like
as a manager like dealing with people
and everything mark also actually
um so i mean they're very like you know
very human people
for in the case of markets uh shockingly
human you know given his uh
his trajectory um
uh
i mean the personality of him that is
painting in the press is just completely
wrong
yeah but you have to know how to play
the press so that's
i i put some of that responsibility on
him
too you have to
it's like um
you know like the director
the conductor of an orchestra you have
to play the press and the public
in a certain kind of way where you
convey your true self to them if there
is a depth and kindness it's hard and
it's hard and it's probably not the best
at it so yeah
you have to learn uh and it's it's sad
to see and i'll talk to him about it but
the shrek is slowly stepping down
it's always uh sad to see folks sort of
be there for a long time and slowly
i guess time i think i think he's done
the thing he
set out to do and you know he's he's got
you know
uh
family priorities and stuff like that
and
um
i understand you know after
13 years or something
it's been a good run which in silicon
valley is basically
a lifetime yeah you know because you
know it's dog years so uh in europe's
the conference just wrapped up uh
let me just go back to something else
you posted the paper you co-authored was
rejected from europe
as you said proudly in quotes rejected
can you joke yeah i know
uh can you describe this paper
and like what was the idea in it and
also maybe this is a good opportunity to
ask what are the pros and cons what
works and what doesn't about the review
process
yeah let me talk about the paper first
i'll talk about the review we'll talk
about the review process uh afterwards
um
the paper is called vkrag so this is i
mentioned that before variance in
variance covariance regularization and
it's a technique a non-contrastive
learning technique for
what i call joint embedding architecture
so siamese nets are an example of joint
invading architecture so gentlemen
architecture is
uh
let me back up a little bit right so if
you want to do supervised running
you can you can do it by prediction
so let's say you want to train your
system to predict video right you show
it a video clip and
and you train the system to predict the
next the continuation of that video clip
now because you need to handle
uncertainty because there are many you
know many continuations that are
plausible
you need to have you need to handle this
in some way you need to have a way for
the system to be able to produce
multiple predictions
and the way the only way i know to do
this
is through what's called a latent
variable so you have some sort of
hidden vector of a variable that you can
vary over a set or draw from a
distribution and as you vary this vector
over a set the output the prediction
varies over a set of plausible
predictions
okay so that's called i call this a
generative latent variable model
okay now there is an alternative to this
to handle uncertainty
and instead of directly predicting the
the next frames of the of the of the
clip
you also run those
through another neural net
uh so you now have two neural nets one
that looks at the
the uh
you know the
initial segment of the video clip and
another one that looks at the the
continuation during training right
and what what you're trying to do is
learn a representation
of those two video clips that is
maximally informative about the video
clips themselves
but
it's such that you can predict the
representation of the second video clip
from the representation of the first one
easily okay
and you can sort of formalize this in
terms of maximizing virtual information
some stuff like that but it doesn't
matter
what you want is
informative representative represent you
know
informative representations of the two
video clips that are mutually
predictable
what that means is that there's a lot of
details in the second video clips that
are irrelevant
you know
i let's say a video clip consists in you
know a camera panning the scene
there's going to be a piece of that room
that is going to be revealed and i can
somewhat predict what the what that room
is going to look like but i may not be
able to predict the details of the
texture of the ground and where the
tiles are ending and stuff like that
right so those are irrelevant details
that perhaps my representation will
eliminate
and so
what i need is to train this second
neural net in such a way that
uh whenever the the
the continuation video clip varies over
all the plausible continuations
the representation doesn't change
got it okay so it's the yeah yeah got it
all over the space of representations
doing the same kind of thing as you're
doing with similarity learning right
yeah so so these are two ways to handle
multi-modality in a prediction right in
the first way you parameterize the
prediction with a latin variable but you
predict pixels essentially right in the
second one you want you don't predict
pixels you predict an abstract
representation of pixels and you
guarantee that this has track
representation
has as much information as possible
about the input but sort of you know
drops all the stuff that you really
can't predict essentially
i used to be a big fan of the first
approach and in fact in this paper with
the chain mishra this this blog post
the dark matter intelligence i was kind
of advocating for this and in the last
year and a half i've completely changed
my mind i'm now a big fan of the second
one
and it's because of
a small collection of algorithms that
have been proposed over the last uh
uh year and a half or so two years
uh to do this uh including v craig
its predecessor called barbie twins
which i mentioned
uh a method from our friends of deepmind
called byol
and and and there's a bunch of others
now that kind of work similarly so
they're all based on this idea of joint
embedding some of them have an explicit
criterion that is an approximation of
mutual information some others will be
aol work but we don't really know why
and there's been like lots of
theoretical papers but why be where it
works no it's not bad because we take it
out and it still works and
you know blah blah blah i mean so
there's like a big big debate but um
uh but the important point is that we
now have a collection of non-contrastive
joint embedding methods which i think is
the best thing since sliced bread so i'm
super excited about this because i think
it's our best shot
for techniques that would allow us to
kind of build
predictive world models and at the same
time learn hierarchical representations
of the world where what matters about
the world is preserved and what is
irrelevant is eliminated
by the way the representation is the
before and after is
in the space
in a sequence of images or is it for
single images uh it would be either for
a single image for a sequence it doesn't
have to be images this could be applied
to text it could be applied to just
about any signal i'm looking at you know
i'm looking for
methods that are generally applicable
that are not specific to you know one
particular modality you know it could be
audio or whatever got it so what's the
story behind this paper this this paper
is what is is describing one of the one
such method this is this vikrant method
so the cisco authored the first author
is a
student called adrian bard who is a
resident phd student at fair paris
who is co-advised by me and jean ponce
who's a professor at economic superior
also a research director at inria
so this is a wonderful program in france
where phd students can basically do
their phd in industry and that's kind of
what what's happening here
and this paper is a follow-up on
the this bottle twin paper by yeah my
former post dog now stefan dunny uh with
li jing and and yurish montar and a
bunch of other people from from from
fair
and
one of the main criticism from reviewers
is that v craig is not different enough
from battle twins but
you know my impression is that
it's you know
bottle twins with a few bugs fixed
essentially and uh in the end this is
what people will use
right so but you know i'm used to stuff
yeah that assume it being rejected
forward so it might be rejected and
actually exceptional excited because
people use it well it's already decided
like a bunch of times so i mean the the
question is then to the deeper question
about peer review and conferences i mean
computer science is a field is kind of
unique that the conference is highly
prized
that's one right and uh it's interesting
because the peer review process there is
similar as opposed to journals but it's
accelerated significantly well not
significantly but it goes fast
and it's nice way to get stuff out
quickly uh to be reviewed quickly go to
present it quickly to the community so
not quickly but quicker yeah but
nevertheless it has many of the same
flaws of uh peer review because it's a
limited number of people look at it
there's bias in the following like that
if you if you want to do new ideas
you're going to get pushed back
um they're self-interested people that
kind of
can infer who submitted it
and kind of
you know be cranky about it all that
kind of stuff yeah i mean there's a lot
of you know social phenomena there um
there's one social phenomenon which is
that because the field has been growing
exponentially
the vast majority of people in the field
are extremely junior yeah so as a
consequence and that's just a
consequence of the field growing right
so as the number of the size of the
field kind of starts saturating you you
will have less of that problem
of reviewers being very uh inexperienced
a consequence of this is that you know
young reviewers
i mean
there's a phenomenon which is that
reviewers try to make their life easy
and to make their life easy when
reviewing a paper
is very simple you just have to find a
flaw in the paper right so
basically they see their task as finding
flaws
in papers and most papers have flaws
even the good ones yeah
um so it's it's easy to you know
to do that you your job is
easier as a reviewer
if you just focus on this but what's
important is
like is there a new idea in that paper
that is likely to influence
it doesn't matter if the experiments are
not that great if the protocol is you
know
uh
so so you know things like that as long
as there is a worthy idea in it
that will influence the way people think
about the problem
um even if they make it better you know
eventually i think that's uh that's
really what what makes a paper useful
and so
this combination of uh social phenomena
creates a a
a disease that has plagued you know
other fields in the past like speech
recognition where basically you know
people chase numbers on uh
on benchmarks
and
and it's much easier to get a paper
accepted if it brings an incremental
improvement on a
sort of mainstream well-accepted
method
or problem
and those are to me boring papers i mean
they're not useless right because uh
industries you know strives on on those
kind of progress
but they're not the one that i'm
interested in in terms of like new
concepts and new ideas so uh papers that
are really uh
trying to strike kind of new advances
generally don't make it
now thankfully we have archive archive
exactly and then there's uh open review
type of situations where you and then i
mean twitter is a kind of open review
i'm a huge believer that reviews should
be done by thousands of people not two
people i agree uh and so archive
like do you see a future where a lot of
really strong papers it's already the
present but a growing future where it'll
just be archived
and
you're presenting an ongoing continuous
conference called twitter and slash the
internet
uh slash archive sanity andre just
released a new version
uh so just not you know not being so
elitist about this particular uh gating
it's not a question of being elitist or
not it's a question of uh being
basically
uh
recommendation and seal of approvals for
people who don't see themselves as
having the ability to do so by
themselves right so it saves time right
if you rely on other people's opinion
and you trust those people
or those
groups to evaluate a paper
for you
that saves you time because you know you
don't have to like scrutinize uh the
paper as much you know it is brought to
your attention i mean it's a whole idea
of sort of you know collective
recommender system right
so i actually thought about this a lot
um you know about 10 15 years ago uh
because there were discussions at
um nips and you know and were about to
create iclear with yoshi banjo and so i
wrote a document
um kind of describing a reviewing system
which basically was you know you post
your paper on some repository let's say
archive or now could be open review um
and then you can form
uh a reviewing entity which is
equivalent to a reviewing board you know
a journal or a
program committee of a conference
you have to list the members
and then
that
group reviewing entity can choose to
review a particular paper
spontaneously or not there is no
exclusive relationship anymore between a
paper and a venue or reviewing entity
any reviewing entity can review any
paper
or may choose not to
and then you know give an evaluation
it's not published or published it's
just an evaluation and a comment which
would be public
signed by the reviewing entity
and
if it's time by reviewing entity you
know it's one of the members of
reviewing entities so if the reviewing
entity is you know
lex treatments
you know preferred papers right you know
it's like friedman writing a review yes
what so for me one that's a beautiful
uh
system i think but what's in addition to
that it feels like there should be a
reputation system for the reviewers
for the reviewing entities not the
reviewers individually the reviewing
entities sure but even within that there
are viewers too because uh
i it's there's another thing here it's
not just the reputation it's an
incentive for an individual person to do
great
right now in in the academic setting the
incentive is kind of uh
internal just wanting to do a good job
but honestly that's not a strong enough
incentive to do a really good job in
reading a paper and finding the
beautiful amidst the mistakes and the
flaws and all that kind of stuff right
like if you're the person that first
discovered a powerful paper
and you get to be proud of that
discovery
then that gives a huge incentive to you
that's that's a big part of my proposal
actually i described that as
you know if if your evaluation of papers
is
predictive of future success yes yes
okay
then your reputation should go up as a
reviewing entity
so yeah exactly i mean that
um i even had a master's student who was
a
master student in uh library science and
computer science actually kind of work
out exactly how that should work with
formulas and everything but so in terms
of implementation do you think that's
something that's doable i mean i've been
sort of you know talking about this to
sort of various people like you know
andrew mccallum who started open review
and the reason why we picked open review
for iclear initially even though it was
very early for them
is because my hope was that
iclear were it was eventually going to
kind of
inaugurate this type of system so iclear
kept the idea of open reviews
so where the reviews are you know
published with the paper which i think
is very useful
but
in many ways that's kind of reverted to
kind of more of a
conventional type conferences for
everything else and that
i mean i
i don't run ikea i'm just the president
of the
foundation but um
you know people who run it should make
decisions about how to run it and i'm
not going to tell them
because they're volunteers and i'm
really thankful that they do that so but
i'm saddened by the fact that
we're not being
innovative enough
yeah me too i hope that changes uh yeah
because the communication of science
broadly but communication computer
science ideas
is how you make those ideas have impact
i think yeah and i think you know a lot
of this is um because people have in
their mind
kind of an objective
which is you know fairness for authors
and the ability to count points
basically and and give credits
accurately
but that comes at the expense of the
progress of science
so to some extent we're slowing down the
progress of science
and are we actually achieving fairness
and we're not achieving fairness you
know we have biases you know we're doing
you know double blind review but
uh
you know the the biases are still there
there are different different kinds of
biases
you write that the phenomenon of
emergence collective behavior exhibited
by a large collection of simple elements
in interaction
is one of the things that got you into
neural nets in the first place i love
cellular automata i love simple
interacting elements and the things that
emerge from them do you think
we understand how complex systems can
emerge from such simple components that
interact simply no we don't
it's a big mystery also it's a mystery
for physicists a mystery for biologists
you know how is it that uh
the uh universe around us seems to be
increasing in complexity and not
decreasing
i mean that that is a kind of a
curious property of uh physics that
despite the second law of thermodynamics
we seem to be you know evolution and
learning and
etc seems to be can at least locally
to increase
complexity not decrease it so perhaps
the ultimate purpose of the universe is
to just get more complex
have these
i mean
uh small pockets of beautiful complexity
does that to sell your automated these
kinds of emergence and complex systems
give you some intuition or guide
your understanding of machine learning
systems and neural networks and so on or
are these for you right now desperate
concepts well you got it got me into it
you know i uh i discovered the existence
of the perceptron when i was a college
student
you know by really good book and it was
a debate between chomsky and piaget and
seymour pepper from mit was kind of
singing the praise of the perception in
that book and i i the first time i heard
about the learning machine right so i
started digging the literature and i
found those paper those books which were
basically trans transcription of you
know
workshops or conferences
from the 50s and 60s about
self-organizing systems so there were
there was a series of conferences on
self-organizing systems and the these
books on this um
some of them are
you can actually get them at the
internet archive you know the
digital version
uh
and there are like uh fascinating
articles in there by this guy whose name
has been largely forgotten heinz von
firster
he's a the german physicist who
immigrated to the u.s
and uh worked on self-organizing systems
uh in the in the 50s
and in the 60s he created at you know
serving in urbana champagne he created a
biological computer laboratory bcl
which was you know all about neural nets
unfortunately that was kind of towards
the end of the popularity of neural nets
so that that lab never kind of strived
very much but but he wrote a bunch of
papers about self-organization and
the mystery of self-organization an
example he has is you take imagine you
are in space there's no gravity you have
a big box with uh
magnets in it okay um you know what kind
of rectangular magnets with north pole
on one end southbound on the other end
you shake the box gently and the magnets
will kind of stick to themselves and
probably form a complex structure
um you know spontaneously
you know that could be an example of
self-organization but you know you have
lots of examples neural nets are an
example of self-organization to
you know in many respects
and it's a it's a bit of a mystery um
you know how
like what what is possible with this um
you know pattern formation in physical
systems
in chaotic system and things like that
you know you know the emergence of life
you know things like that so you know
how does
does that happen
it's a it's a big puzzle for for
physicists as well it feels like
understanding this
the the mathematics
of emergence in some constrained
situations might help us create
intelligence
like uh help us add a little spice to
the systems because um you seem to be
able to
in complex systems with emergence to be
able to get a lot from little
and so that seems like a shortcut
to get big leaps in performance
but um but there's there's a missing
conservative concept that we are we
don't have yeah uh and it's uh it's
something also i've been fascinated by
since uh my undergrad days and it's how
you measure complexity
right so we don't actually have good
ways of measuring or at least we don't
have good ways of interpreting
the measures that we we have at our
disposal like how do you measure the
complexity of something right so there's
all those things you know like you know
common goal of chatting solomon of
complexity of you know the length of the
shortest program that would generate a b
string can be thought of as the
complexity of that bit string right
um
i've been fascinated by that concept the
problem with that is that
that complexity is defined up to a
constant which can be very large
right there's there are similar concepts
that are derived from you know
you know bayesian probability theory
where you know the complexity of
something is
the negative log of its probability
essentially right and you have a
complete equivalence between the two
things
and there you would think you know the
probability is something that's well
defined mathematically which means
complexity is well-defined but it's not
true you need to have a model of
of of the distribution
and you may need to have a prior if
you're doing bayesian inference and the
prior plays the same role as the choice
of the computer with which you measure
your graph complexity and so every
measure of complexity we have has some
arbitrary necessity
um
you know an additive constant which
is can be arbitrarily large and so
you know how can we come up with a good
theory of how things become more complex
if we don't have a good measure of
complexity yeah which we need for this
one way that people study this in the
space of biology the people that study
the origin of life or try to recreate
the life in in the laboratory
and the more interesting one is the
alien one is when we go to other planets
how do we recognize this life
because you know complexity we associate
complexity maybe some level of mobility
with life
you know we have to be able to like have
concrete
algorithms for like
um measuring the level of complexity we
see in order to know the difference
between life and non-life and the
problem is that complexity is in the eye
of the beholder so let me give you an
example if i um if i give you uh
an image of the endless digits right and
i flip through any digits there is some
obviously some
structure to it because
local structure you know neighboring
pixels are correlated uh
across the entire data set
now imagine that
i apply a random permutation to all the
pixels
a fixed random permutation now i show
you those images they will look
you know really disorganized to you more
complex
in fact they're not more complex in
absolute terms they're exactly the same
as originally right and if you knew what
the permutation was you know you could
undo the permutation now
imagine i give you special glasses that
undo that permutation
now all of a sudden what looked
complicated becomes simple right so if
you have two
if you have you know humans on one end
and then another race of aliens that
sees the universe with permutation
glasses yeah with the permutation
glasses
what we perceive as simple to them is
hardly complicated it's probably heat
yeah heat yeah okay and what they
perceive as simple to us is is random uh
fluctuation it's heat yeah
so truly in the eye of the beholder it
depends what kind of glasses you're
wearing right depends what kind of
algorithm you're running in your
perception system so i don't think we'll
have a theory of intelligence
self-organization evolution things like
that until we have a good handle on
a notion of complexity which we know is
in the higher the eye of the beholder
yeah it's sad to think that we might not
be able to detect or interact with alien
species because we're wearing different
glasses
um because their notion of locality
might be different from ours yeah this
actually connects with fascinating
questions in physics at the moment like
modern physics
quantum physics like you know
questions about like you know can we
recover the information that's lost in a
black hole and things like this right
and uh and that relies on notions of
complexity um
yeah which you know i find i find this
fascinating can you describe your
personal quest to build an expressive
electronic
wind instrument ewi
what is it what does it take
to uh to build it well i'm a tinkerer i
like building things
i like building things with combinations
of electronics and you know mechanical
stuff
um you know i have a bunch of different
hobbies but um
you know probably my first one was
little was building model airplanes and
stuff like that and i still do that to
some extent
but also electronics i taught myself
electronics before i studied it
and the reason i taught myself
electronics is because of music
my cousin
was an aspiring electronic musician and
he had an analog synthesizer and i was
you know basically modifying it for him
and building sequencers and stuff like
that right for him i was i was in high
school when i was doing this
that's the interesting like progressive
rock like 80s
like what's what's the greatest band of
all time according to yala [ __ ] um
there's two there's too many of them but
you know it's a combination of uh
uh
you know my vision orchestra uh
weather report yes
genesis uh you know yes
gentle giant you know things like that
great
okay so this uh this level of
electronics and this love of music
combined together right so i was
actually trying to play a
baroque and renaissance
music and i played in a
orchestra when i was in high school in
uh first years of college
and i played the recorder chrome horn a
little bit of oboe you know things like
that so i'm a win instrument player but
i always wanted to play improvised music
even though i don't know anything about
it
uh and the only way i figured you know
short of like learning to play saxophone
was to
play electronic instruments so they
behave like the fingering is similar to
a saxophone but you know you have wide
variety of sound because you control the
synthesizer with it so i had a bunch of
those you know going back to the late
80s
from either
yamaha or
akai they they're both kind of the main
manufacturers of those so they were
classically you know going back several
decades
uh but i've never been completely
satisfied with them because of lack of
exclusivity
and you know those things you know are
somewhat expensive i mean they measure
the breast pressure they measure the lip
pressure and you know
uh
you have like various parameters you can
you can vary it with fingers but they
they they're not really as expressive as
a acoustic instrument right you um you
hear john coltrane play two notes and
you hear you know his john cochrane you
know he's got a unique sound
uh or or mike davis right you can hear
his mice davis
uh playing the trumpet because the the
sound
reflects their
you know physiology basically the shape
of the vocal tract
um
kind of shapes the the sound so how how
do you do this with uh electronic
instrument and i was
many years ago i met a guy called david
wessel he
he was a professor at berkeley and
created the
center for like you know music
technology there and he was interested
in that question
and so i kept kind of thinking about
this for many years and finally because
i covered you know i was at home i was
in my workshop my workshop serves also
as my kind of zoom uh
room and
home office and this is in new jersey in
new jersey and um i started uh
really being serious about you know
building my own ewe instrument what else
is going on in that new jersey workshop
is there some is there some crazy stuff
you built like just or or like left on
the workshop floor
left behind a lot of crazy stuff is uh
you know electronics with built with
microcontrollers of various kinds
and you know
weird flying contraptions
so you still love flying
it's a family disease my my dad got me
into it when i was a kid
and
he was building model airplanes when he
was a kid and uh and he was a mechanical
engineer he taught himself electronics
also so he he built his early radio
control systems in the
late 60s early 70s
um and so that that's what got me into i
mean he got me into kind of you know
engineering and science and technology
do you also have an interest in
appreciation of flight in other forms
like with drones quadropters or do you
do yes is it model airplane the thing
you know i
you know before drones were
you know kind of a
consumer product
um you know i built my own you know with
also building a microcontroller with uh
gyroscopes and accelerometers for
stabilization writing the firmware for
it you know and then when it became kind
of a standard thing you could buy it was
boring you know i stopped doing it it
was not fun anymore um yeah
you were doing it before it was cool
yeah what uh advice would you give to a
young person today in high school and
college that
dreams of doing
something big like young lacoon like
let's talk in the space of intelligence
dreams of having a chance to solve some
fundamental problems in space of
intelligence
both for their career and just in life
being somebody who was a part of
creating something special
so
try to get
interested by big questions things like
you know
what is intelligence uh
what is the universe made of what's life
all about things like that
um
like even like crazy big questions like
um what's time like nobody knows what
time is
and
and then
learn
basic things like basic methods either
from math from physics or from
engineering
things that have a long shelf life
like if you have a choice between like
you know
learning uh you know mobile programming
on iphone
or quantum mechanics take quantum
mechanics
um because you're going to learn things
that you have no idea exist it and you
may not you nev you know you may never
be a quantum physicist
but you will learn about path integrals
and path integrals are used uh
everywhere it's the same formula that
you use for you know bayesian
integration and stuff like that so the
ideas the little ideas
within quantum mechanics
within some of these kind of more
solidified fields will have a longer
shelf life that you'll somehow
use indirectly in in your work learn
classical mechanics like you learn about
lagrangians for example
um
which is like a huge
hugely useful concept you know for all
kinds of different things uh
learn uh statistical physics because uh
all the math that comes out of you know
for machine learning
uh basically comes out of uh was figured
out by statistical physicists in the you
know late 19th early 20th century right
so
uh and for some of them actually more
recently for by people like giorgio
perezi who just got a nobel prize for
the replica method among other things um
it's used for a lot of different things
uh you know variational inference
that math comes from statistical physics
so
um
so a lot of those kind of you know
busy courses you know you'll if you do
electrical engineering you take signal
processing you'll you'll learn about
fourier transforms
again something super useful
it's at the basis of things like graph
neural nets which is an entirely new
sub area of you know ai machine learning
deep learning which i think is super
promising for all kinds of applications
something very promising if you're more
interested in applications is the
applications of ai machine learning and
deep learning to science
or to
science that can help solve big problems
in the world like i have colleagues at
uh at meta at fair
we started this project called open
catalyst and it's
it's an open project collaborative
and the idea is to use deep learning to
help design
new chemical compounds or materials that
would facilitate the separation of
hydrogen from oxygen
if you can efficiently separate oxygen
from hydrogen with electricity
you you solve climate change
it's as simple as that because
you you cover you know some random
desert with uh solar panels
uh and you have have them work all day
produce hydrogen and then you shoot the
adrenaline wherever it's needed you
don't need anything else
uh
you know you you have
controllable
power that's you know can be transported
anywhere so if we if we have a
large-scale efficient
uh energy storage technology like
producing hydrogen
we solve climate change here's another
way to solve climate change
is uh figuring out how to make fusion
work now the problem with fusion is that
you make a super hot plasma and the
plasma is unstable and you can't control
it maybe with deep learning you can find
controllers that will sterilize plasma
and make you know practical fusion
reactors
i mean that's very speculative but you
know it's worth trying because
um you know
the payoff is huge there's a group at
google working on this led by john platt
so control
convert as many problems in science and
physics and biology and chemistry into a
into a learnable problem and see if a
machine can learn it
right i mean there's properties of uh
you know complex materials that we don't
understand from first principle for
example right so you know if we could
design uh new um
you know new materials
uh we could make more efficient
batteries you know we could make maybe
faster electronics we could i mean
there's a lot of things we can imagine
uh doing or you know lighter uh
materials for for cars or airplanes and
things like that maybe better fuel cells
i mean there's all kinds of stuff we can
imagine if we had good fuel cells
hydrogen fuel cells uh we could use them
to power airplanes and you know
transportation wouldn't be uh or cars
and we wouldn't have uh
emission problem uh co2 emission
problems for for
uh air transportation anymore so
there's a lot of those things i think
where ai you know can be used it
and this is not even talking about all
the sort of medicine biology and and
everything like that right
you know like you know
protein folding you know figuring out
like how can you design your proteins
that it sticks to another protein at a
particular site because that's how you
design drugs in the end
um so you know diploma would be used for
all of this and those are kind of you
know would be sort of enormous progress
if we could uh use it for that here's an
example if you take
this is like from recent material
physics you take a monoatomic layer of
graphene right so it's just carbon
on a hexagonal mesh and you make this
single single atom thick
you put another one on top you twist
them by some magic number of degrees
three degrees or something
it becomes super conductor
nobody has any idea why
uh i want to know how that was
discovered but that's the kind of thing
that machine learning can actually
discover these well thanks maybe not but
but there is uh
a hint perhaps that with machine
learning we could train a system to
basically be a phenomenological model of
some complex emerging phenomenon which
you know
superconductivity is one of those
uh
where you know think the the skeletal
phenomenon is too difficult to describe
from first principles with the current
you know
the usual sort of you know reductionist
type method but we could
have deep learning systems that predict
the properties
of a system from a description of it
after being trained with sufficiently
many samples
this guy pascal fuad epfl he has a
starter company
that
where he basically trained uh a
convolutional net essentially to
predict the aerodynamic properties of
solids
and you can generate as much data as you
want by just running computational free
dynamics right so you give a
like a
a wing
airfoil or something shape of some kind
and you run computational free dynamics
you get as a result the
drag and you know lyft and all that
stuff right and you can you can generate
lots of data train a neural net to make
those predictions and now what you have
is a differentiable model
of let's say dragon and lift as a
function of the shape of that solid and
so you can do backward understand you
can optimize the shape so you get the
properties you want
yeah that's incredible that's incredible
and on top of all that
probably
you should read a little bit of
literature and a little bit of history
for
inspiration and for wisdom because after
all all these technologies will have to
work in the human world yes and the
human world is complicated
yeah and this is um
an amazing conversation i'm really
honored that you talked with me today
thank you for all the amazing work
you're doing at fair at meta
and thank you for being so passionate
after all these years about everything
that's going on you're you're a beacon
of hope for the machine learning
community and thank you so much for
spending your valuable time with me
today that was awesome thanks for having
me on that was it was a pleasure
thanks for listening to this
conversation with younla kun to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from isaac asimov
your assumptions are your windows on the
world
scrub them off every once in a while or
the light won't come in
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time